[Musique]
messieurs dames bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement Julia
cager ben moi je m'appelle Julia cager
je suis chercheuse en sciences sociales
euh et puis on vient de publier un livre
avec Thomas court 864 pages qui
s'appelle une histoire du conflit
politique et Thomas Thomas picketti donc
également chercheur en sciences sociales
euh c'est c'est c'est un livre qui se
lit très bien hein en fait c'est très
lible ça ça c'est il faut juste il
prendre un peu de temps tranquillement
on n'est pas pressé mais ça se lit très
bien il y a un très bon site internet
aussi qui va avec une histoire du confl
et puis en plus on peut caler un bus
dans une montagne avec parce que c'est
un bon pavé oui c'est vrai mais al il y
a un résumé en ligne sur le site qui
résume tout en trois paragraphes par
chapitre puis ça peut donner envie de
bon ça y est 27 € aussi c'est au quelles
éditions ça y est on a fait le ah mais
c'est au seuil voilà faut arrêtez vos
conneries parce que jeis me faer mais le
site il est gratuit le site est gratuit
on a décidé de vous faire venir ce soir
pour parler de plein de choses
euh comment vous jugez la politique du
gouvernement pour endiguer l'inflation
en France vas-y commence c'est pas pas
terrible voilà bon mais franchement
économiste toi non ouais non pas
spécialement moi moi je m'intéresse plus
à l'histoire l'économie politique mais
d'un point de vue historique que qu'à la
conjoncture écho voilà prévoir
l'inflation moi c'est pas trop bon truc
mais en un mot je pense qu'il aurait
fallu beaucoup plus bloquer les prix
c'est on laisse les prix de l'énergie es
de gauche
aussi bah moi je suis je suis d'abord un
chercheur en Scien sociales j'aime je je
trouve qu'il y a une progression vers
plus d'égalité dans l'histoire qui je
trouve a plutôt bien fonctionné tu vois
l'égalité face au droit de vote
l'égalité mais aussi face au au revenus
au patrimoine qui sont quand même moins
incroyablement concentré aujourd'hui
qu'il y a un siècle qu'il y a deux
siècles bah grâce essentiellement à des
mobilisations politique et social qui
ont permis d'imposer la sécurité sociale
l'école gratuite l'impôt progressif à
des élites qui n'en voulaient pas et qui
aujourd'hui encore ne veulent pas de
changement et donc moi je constate que
dans l'histoire bah c'est changement ils
finissent quand même par se produire
c'est pas facile et à la fin tout le
monde finit par accepter c'est
aujourd'hui personne veut revenir au 19e
siècle supprimer la sécurité sociale
supprimer l'école gratuite supprimer
l'impôt progressif donc moi je pense que
ce mouvement va continuer peut continuer
mais il faut que la la lutte continue et
un des moyens de la lutte c'est les
élections et c'est le sujet de notre
bouquin sur une histoire du conflit
politique tu es pas venu pour parler de
tonouquin ce soir ouais mais je vais
quand même en parler même si tu veux pas
parce que parce que ça fait partie des
instruments de la lutte alors c'est pas
le seul il a des mobilisations social il
y a voilà toutes les moyens d'action
mais les les élections compte aussi et
donc et donc nous dans dans ce bouquin
avec Julia on a voulu essayer de
comprendre qui vote pour qui pourquoi
depuis depuis deux siècles depuis la
Révolution française qui est un peu la
naissance des des des élections c'est un
moment qu'on qu'on étudie pas assez mais
qui a un truc incroyable c'estàdire que
tu tu te mets à tu fais voter 6 millions
de personne dans les années 1790 1781
1792 en France al ça reste limité aux
hommes mais c'est presque 70 80 % des
hommes ce que tu soulèves là pourquoi on
a donné le droit de vote aux femmes ah
ben je répondre à ça non vas-y parce que
bon c'est quand même une réponse qui
s'adresse directement aux femmes
pourquoi non non mais la question
pourquoi on leur a pas donné avant
d'ailleurs c'est assz intéressant dès
1789 tu as des femmes qui veulent voter
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que les
hommes en fait ont peur des femmes d'une
certaine manière et ça se voit jusqu'en
1944 on donne super tard le droit droit
de vote aux femmes en France et
d'ailleurs on regarde toutes les
mobilisations des des suffragettes en
Angleterre tout au long du fin 19e début
20e siècle je dire les hommes sont
prêtes à mettre les femmes en prison
pour les empêcher d'aller voter donc il
faut quand même avoir vachement peur des
femmes pour prendre plus de 150 ans
d'histoire électorale mettre des femmes
en prison arrêter des manifestations les
les les réprimer dans la dans la
violence parce qu'on a peur que les
femmes votent et ce qui est complètement
fou à l'époque quand on donne le droit
de vote aux femmes en 1944 enfin en
France parce qu' on s'y prend vraiment
tard en comparaison internationale on on
on a peur qu'elle vote comme le curé
donc à ce moment-là on se dit bah ouais
si on leur donne le droit de vote elles
vont être complètement influencé et
d'ailleurs elles vont voter trop à
droite alors qu'aujourd'hui si on
regarde la manière dont les femmes
votent elles votent beaucoup plus à
gauche que les hommes c'est intéressant
de comprendre pourquoi il y a une partie
qui est d à un effet purement revenu si
je puis dire c'estàd que les femmes en
moyenne ont des revenus plus faibles
elles sont davantage précarisé mais même
si on contrôle pour tout ça il y a quand
même un survote des femmes à gauche
parce qu'en fait elles sont plus bah
dans le progrès social dans la
mobilisation dans dans l'acquisition de
de nouveaux droits donc c'est quand même
plutôt une bonne chose de leur avoir
donné le droit de vote on aurait pu le
faire avant quand même d' en plus c'est
vachement bien maintenant on peut les
taxer ouais oui alors attends il y a des
pays ça a été encore plus tard en Suisse
c'est 1971 parce que comme c'était des
référendums avec des hommes référendum
après référendum ils étaient contre mais
finalement finalement ça a passé mais
mais quand même pour revenir à la
Révolution
françaiseir question je reviens à ta
question question question juger la
politique du gouvernement pour mais
parce qu'on s' on s'en fout de celle-là
mais là non mais mais juste la
Révolution française c'est important tu
as 6 millions de personnes qui vont
voter dans les années 1790 juste pour
comparer tu vois les les cités greces
dans l'Antiquité quand tu as 10000
électeurs c'est le maximum et le
Royaume-Uni les États-Unis dans dans les
années 1790 c'est c'est 200000 300000
électeurs en France tu as 6 millions
d'électeurs c'est vraiment la naissance
à l'échelle de mondiale quoi enfin de
l'histoire mondial de de de la
démocratie électorale à grande échelle
et donc nous on commence notre histoire
par là et c'est un moment incroyable à
étudier dans les dans les archives
électorales parce que les gens à
l'époque pour aller pour aller voter
pour aller voter tu sais faut aller au
chef-lieu de canton donc tu marches 20
30 k enfin c'est une aventure d'aller
voter g c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant par rapport aux femmes parce
que tu as les histoiriens racontent ça
très bien du coup tu as 20 30 km de
marche pour aller au chef-lieu de canton
mais il y a que les hommes qui vont
voter donc ça veut dire quoi
concrètement qu' partent tous les hommes
hors du village en laissant que les
femmes et les enfants donc en fait ils
ont peur d'aller voter parce qu'ils ont
peur que le village fasse attaquer
piller et que les femmes se fassent
violer donc en fait ils auraient mieux
fait de donner le droit d' aux femmes
directement elles auraient pu aller
voter avec eux ils auraient eu moins
peur qu'ell se fasse violer en leur
absence mais il ils vont voter ils vont
voter quand même 30 40 50 % de taux de
participation ce qui est pas rien vu les
difficultés pour se déplacer pour aller
voter le fait qu'à l'époque tu as pas
des journaux faciles tu as pas sur tu as
pas enfin tu t'informes c'est plus
compliqué quand même pour s'informer ils
y vont et après ça va continuer de
monter à part à partir de 1848 qui est
le retour du suffrage universel parce
qu'il y a toute une période de 1815 à
1848 où pour avoir le droit de voter
c'est que les 1 ou 2 % les plus riches
faut payer assez d'impôts donc c'est
comme si tu avais que les contrubles ISF
qui ont le droit de voter ce qui quand
même un peu sera un peu gonflé comme
système à l'époque notre monnaie était
adossée sur quoi oh B c'était l'or un
peu partout là à l'époque et en 1848 on
recommence le droit de vote pour pour
tous les hommes et là tu as 70 80 % de
participation jusqu'aux années 1980 1990
pendant un siècle et demi on est
toujours à à 70 80 % de participation et
là depuis les années 90 on est tombé là
aux dernières élections on est à 48 % en
2022 ce qui est le plus bas niveau
depuis la Révolution française donc on
est on est revenu comment vous expliquez
ça ah là pour le coup on peut parler du
gouvernement Macron non mais pas que on
va l'expliquer quand même pas uniquement
avec la situation politique actuelleant
avant que tu commences j'ai j'ai juste
une question à posée un peu chiante
est-ce que être de gauche ou de droite
est nuisible à la perception de la
réalité économique sociologique et non
parce que sinon ça vudrait enfin je
pense que tous les citoyens sont de
gauche de droite ça peut changer ça
voudrait dire que tout le monde a une
espèce de perception biaisée du monde tu
on est tous citoyens on a tous des
préférences politiques parfois elles
changent parfois elle change pas ça ça
ça ça bien sûr ça ça fait poser un
regard différent sur le monde c'est pas
tellement que ça biaiseise la perception
d'une certaine manière je pense que ça
change les questions qu'on a envie de
poser ça change les questions auquelles
on a envie de répondre dans tous les cas
c'est pas figé tu vois les identités
elles sont pas figées les croyances sont
pas figées nous on croit d'abord dans la
confrontation dans la délibération tu
vois si les gens étaient confrontation
l'échange bah l'échange mais qui peut
être musclé on appelle notre bouquin une
histoire du conflit politique mais pour
nous le conflit politique c'est pas tout
mal enfin c'est même on pense que la
démocratieis le sous-titre c'est
élection inégalité sociale 1789 20022 on
pense que la démocratie électorale elle
s'est construite aussi dans le fait
d'assumer l'existence de conflit
politique et nous on est d'abord d'abord
tu vois des militants de l'alternance
démocratique c'est c'est vrai qu'on a
plutôt tendance à voter à gauche qu'à
droite mais on dit pas que la gauche
doit être tout le temps au pouvoir on
pense que c'est bien d'avoir parfois la
gauche la droite et on pense que c'est
bien d'avoir deux blocs politiques avec
l'un qui est plutôt plus favorisé
socialement en moyenne historiquement
c'est plutôt la droite l'autre qui est
plutôt plus défavorisant en moyenne
historiquement c'est plutôt la gauche
mais chacun a des choses à apporter
c'est le fait d'avoir eu plus de
réussite sur le plan économique ça veut
pas dire qu'on a tort on peut avoir des
choses à apporter et inversement la
difficulté aujourd'hui tu vois dans le
truc dans le bloc Macron c'est que tu as
un côté voilà c'est moi ou le chaos
c'est de j'ai l'extrême un extrême
gauche d' côté l'extrême de l'autre côté
la raison c'est moi et il y a pas
d'alternance démocratique tu délégitimes
par avance tu vois la possibilité d'une
alternance et ça il délégitime le
conflit politique en fait d'une certaine
façon ça délégitime le fait que le
conflit politique l'alternance c'est ça
comment tu juges les 15 15 ou 17 493
qu'on vient de se prendre là alors je
crois qu'on vient de se prendre le 19e
là j'ai pas fait exactement mon mon mon
décompte précis bah typiquement c'est le
refus de de la délibération politique
c'est le refus du conflit politique
alors on va dire on a ils sont ils ont
pas d'autres choix de le faire parce
qu'ils ont pas de de majorité mais ils
ont pas de majorité justement à la
limite le le le rôle d'un gouvernement
c'est d'aller construire une majorité on
devrait aller construire une majorité
sur le projet de loi de finance sur le
projet de loi de finance pour la
sécurité sociale donc il y a déjà ça
c'est-à-dire ce ce ce refus finalement
d'essayer bah de trouver un équilibre
des forces et puis de s'assumer alors ça
pourrait être alors Macron il dit ni
droite ni gauche bon ça fait quand même
longtemps que c'est beaucoup plus à
droite mais il veut pas quand même
s'assumer entièrement sur la droite quoi
qu'il est en train quand même carrément
de le faire avec la loi immigration donc
il y a le le le refus finalement d'
d'aller reconstruire un nouveau clivage
politique ça c'est le premier truc et le
deuxième truc sur sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui là tout le monde se focalise
sur le 493 mais c'est pas tellement le
493 c'est la manière dont ça a lieu
c'estàdire qu'il y a souvent eu des 493
sur des projets de lois de finances ou
des projets de loi sécurité sociale mais
là il y a pas de débat c'està qu'elle
prend même pas le temps je dis elle
ellisabeth borne elle prend même pas le
temps en fait d'avoir un débat de de
faire voter des amendements de
l'opposition et cetera elle va direct à
chaque 493 sauf que tu as des
amendements qui seraient intéressant et
qui pourrait être intéressant y compris
pour la majorité macroniste tu vois
quand qu'on fasse une expérience de
pensée tous les trois je voudrait que
vous défendiez ellisabeth borne et les
493 non mais le écoute on a plein de
pays autour de nous toi qui fonctionne
très bien 1493 et s'il y avait pas le
493 bah en fait tous les pays la France
l'Italie ils ont à peu près l'équivalent
et mélonie en abuse pas mal mais ouai
mais bon la plupart la plupart en ont
pas la plupart en ont pas et qu'est-ce
qui se passerait tu vois s'il y Ava pas
le 43 bah ça obligerait simplement le le
le la majorité macronienne à s'entendre
avec LR et dans le fond ils sont pas
très différents c'estd dans le fond le
programme qu'ils ont à mettre en œuvre
est assez proche les républicain et donc
voilà il ils assumeraient de former une
majorité et puis ce serait il y aurait
quelque chose de plus sa sur le plan
démocratique souvent on dit rard a fait
encore plus de 493 que Bor mais dans le
fond c'était aussi une une connerie
c'estàdire que rard il était pas loin
d'avoir la majorité il lui manquait des
députés communistes à l'époque avec qui
après l'expérience de 81 il voulaiit
plus gouverner ensemble sauf qu'en fait
s'il y avait pas eu de 493 bah ils
auraient été obligés justement de de
trouver des compromis avec les
communistes et je pense que ça leur
aurait fait du bien je pense qu'entre 88
et 93 la gauche aurait été bah peut-être
un peu plus à gauche aurait été obligé
au lieu de se lancer par exemple dans la
la grande course poursuite au dumping
fiscal sur la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés ça commence à ce moment-là
entre 88 et 93 les socialistes font
passer le taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés de 50 à 33 % puis après ça va
continuer avec l'Irlande à 20 à 15 vers
0 % assez bizarrement c'est les
socialistes français ont beaucoup
contribué à lancer ce mouvement bah
s'ils avaient dû se mettre d'accord avec
les communistes sur les lois de finances
à l'époque sans doute ils auraient pas
pu faire ça donc voilà la 493 ça a
toujours été un quelque chose je pense
de négatif plutôt pour la défendre 2
minutes Elisabeth born en disant en fait
c'est la faute d'Emmanuel Macron à un
moment donné Emmanuel Macron prend une
première ministre à qui il laisse pas de
place politique il prend une première
ministre volon volontairement faible il
l'affaiblit volontairement dès le départ
en fait il la nomme en se disant bah
est-ce que je vais la laisser plus ou
moins longtemps kedit cresson il lui
donne pas de de de pouvoir d'une
certaine manière donc elle a pas
finalement l'assise politique pour aller
chercher un équilibre et pour aller
chercher des voies à droite à gauche
trouver donc en fait c'est davantage
quand même la la responsabilité
d'Emmanuel Macron que celle d'Élisabeth
borne mais pour revenir ta question
c'est sa pourquoi la la la participation
électorale a chuté autant là et et donc
c'est ce que tu as proposé tout à
l'heure on n pas répondu mais on peut
aussi pas répondre si tu veux mais je
pense que c'est quand même c'est quand
même une question intéressante puisque
là on a aux dernières élections on est
tombé à 48 % de de participation les
élections législatif 2022 en fait c'est
encore moins que ça parce que tu as 10 %
des gens qui sont pas inscrits sur la
liste électorale donc si tu calcules par
rapport aux gens qui ont le droit de
vote tu
tomberais 40 % quoi ser tuis c'est quand
même et alors l'autre fait que nous on
met en évidence et qui permett de donner
des éléments d'explication nous ce qu'on
fait d'abord dans ce bouquin c'est
d'essayer de rassembler à partir des
archives nationales des données ou mais
tu t'en fous mais moi j'en parle quand
même c'est comme ça vend bien votre
bouquin ou ça se vend très bien mais
combi oh écoute là je sais pas on n pas
regardé les derniers chiffres mais ça se
vent
ça non franchement je sais pas la
dernière fois qu'on nous l'avait dit on
avait fait mieux qu'injupé je très
rassurant avait aussi doublé SAR quoi
c'est pas
forcément non non non en septembre ça
mais bon non mais franchement je je je
je sais pas mais ce que je sais c'est
que c'est que tu ne sais rien non écoute
et ben nous alors on sait un peu plus de
choses après avoir écrit le bouquin
qu'avant l'avoir écit mais on sa bien il
y a plein de cartes il y a plein de
sources il y a plein de choses non mais
c'est surtout si tu veux comment est-ce
que c'est une pointe de diamant pour
pouvoir se positionner pour les
prochaines élections non mais alors mais
vraiment mais pas du tout mais c'est
tellement à côté là non franchement là
le but c'est simplement d'essayer de
connaître un peu plus de choses sur qui
vote pour qui et pourquoi donc
concrètement pour dire les choses très
façon on le fait parce que jusqu'ici tu
vois le ministère de l'intérieur après
qu'on ait voté il ne rend publique la
façon dont les gens ont voté dans des
fichiers au niveau des 36000 communes
que depuis les législatives de 1993 et
nous on a voulu depuis la Révolution
française numériser les données qui
étaient en fait aux Archives nationales
alors c'est des archives manuscrit et
cetera mais qu'on pouvait numériser et
donc nous notre bouquin ça ça se base
sur une d'abord une démarche de numérque
tion de toutes les données avec les
principaux référendum depuis 1793
jusqu'au référendum européen de 2005
toutes les législative depuis 1848
toutes les présidentielles depuis 1848
au niveau des 36000 communes et ça nous
permet de savoir quoi bah déjà sur la
question de est-ce que les gens votent
ou pas premier résultat la chute de la
participation là en 2022 c'est la la
chute la plus forte depuis l'époque de
la Révolution française deuxème résultat
qui est quand même très frappant et que
nous en tout cas on savait pas avant
jamais on a vu un tel écart entre les
communes riches et les communes pauvres
c'estd si tu prends là en 2022 les les
10 % des communes les plus riches par
rapport au 10 % des communes les plus
pauvres tu as un écart le le les 10 %
des communes les plus riches vont voter
1,3 1,4 fois plus que les 10 % des
communes les plus pauvres donc avec une
une participation qui est tombée à 48 %
ou même à à peine 40 % tu ça veut dire
que les communes les plus pauvres sont à
30 et les autres à 50 enfin donc et ça
on avait jamais vu un écart pareil et
c'est c'est vachement important parce
que parfois les gens s'imaginent bon
c'est toujours comme ça les plus riches
votent plus que les plus pas du tout ce
qu'on montre aussi dans le bouquin c'est
qu'en fait par dans les années 60 70 80
c'est le contraire les communes les plus
beau votent plus que les communes les
plus riches et c'est lié à une
mobilisation politique on disait tout à
l'heure les luttes sociales tout ça bon
bah là c'est vrai que c'est vrai c'est
lié à par exle une mobilisation pour le
parti communiste dans des banlieux
ouvrières pauvres mais pour l'union de
la gauche en général c'est lié à des à
des aussi à des voilà des stratégies
politiques à des à des milit maintenant
ça et ben sans doute parce que les gens
depuis depuis les années 80 90 ont eu
l'impression que aussi alors ça a joué
mais de façon générale le centre droit
au pouvoir le centre gauche au pouvoir
peut-être faisait un peu la même chose
et les gens se sont dit bon finalement à
quoi ça sert d'aller voter et tu as
raison que les référendum européens de
92 et 2005 c'est un peu un des moments
où la la l'espèce de coalition
macroniste qu'on a aujourd'hui où les
les électeurs un peu les plus favorisés
du centre droit du centre gauche se
retrouve ensemble et puis laisse un peu
de côté le le reste de la de la
population qui se oublié par la
mondialisation par par la construction
européenne de de de nature très libérale
bon nous on pense qu'il y a une autre
façon d'organiser l'Europe la
mondialisation et cetera nous on n'est
pas du tout replié sur l'État nation on
est pour l'ouverture l'internationalisme
mais la façon dont ça s'est fait a quand
même plutôt favoriser les classes qui
étaient les les plus favorisé et donc ce
retrait de la politique c'est c'est en
partie cette déception ce sentiment
d'abandon tu veux ouais même reven sur
sur tu vois pourquoi on a fait le
bouquin il y a un moment donné aussi bah
par exemple ce que dit Thomas sur sur la
participation tu vois cette idée que
tout le monde dit en permanence ah bah
oui ça serait une vérité vraie de tout
temps les plus pauvres votent moins que
les plus riches on nous dit pourquoi ah
bah les plus pauvres ils sont moins
éduqués en moyenne ils sont moins
éduqués ils sont moins bien informés ils
sont moins bien informés ils sont moins
politisés ils votent moins bon sauf
qu'en fait c'est pas vrai si c'était
vrai mais il devait on devrait voir
qu'il vote moins dans les années 60 70
80 c'était pas le cas donc en fait on
essaie un peu de les montrer du doigt
tuis de les culpabiliser alors que là on
voit que c'est une décision finalement
rationnelle de de de pas aller aux urnes
et on peut essayer de comprendre ce
choix qui est dû aussi à une
insatisfaction du pouvoir en place on
peut revenir sur ce fait par exemple un
des points centrals qu'on a le le vote
Macron le plus bourgeois de l'histoire
bon ben ça peut décourager les plus
modestes de pas aller voter et en fait
il y a un certain nombre de choses comme
ça qui nous énervaient beaucoup de
contrevérité dans le dans le dans le
débat public je prendre deux autres
exemples il y a un exemple sur le le
vote de gauche c'est tu ouvres ces news
où tuachètes le point le point est titré
il y a encore encore même pas 6 mois
pire que le pire que le la la gauche
bobo non attends c'était quoi pire que
la gauche cavoir que la gauche caviè les
bobo mélanchonistes et tu ouvrais le
point tu avais l'impression que tous les
électeurs de gauche étaient des
électeurs favorisés et que toutes les
classes populaires avaient abandonn la
gauche sauf qu'un des trucs qu'on montre
dans le livre et pour le coup c'est
systématique de 1848 à aujourd'hui c'est
encore plus fort aujourd'hui qu'il y a
30 ans c'est que les classes populaires
votent davantage à gauche et que le plus
riche ne vote pas à gauche et qu'on a un
effondrement du du vote pour la gauche
plus tu montes dans la distribution du
du revenu des des communes et ça c'est
un fait et ce fait on l'a mis en ligne
avec des chiffres documentés depuis 3
mois il y a personne qui est venu le le
le contester c'est important en fait de
rétablir un certain nombre de vérités
dans le débat public de rappeler par
exemple que quand le point dit les
classes populaires ont abandonné la
gauche le point dit une contrevérité sur
quoi il base cette contrevérité sur le
vê qu'il vont entièrement identifier
classe populaire et ouvriers et c'est
vrai que les ouvriers votent moins à
gauche aujourd'hui et votent davantage
rassemblement national sauf qu'en fait
les classes populaires c'est pas
uniquement les ouvriers tu as les
ouvriers tu as les employés il se trouve
que depuis 30 ans en France les employés
en France ont un revenu moyen inférieur
à celui des ouvriers c'est des
travailleurs précaires c'est des
travailleurs dans le secteur de du soin
c'est du nettoyage c'est des caissières
c'est les travailleurs de la
restauration c'est des employés leors
salaire moyen il est inférieur à celui
des des des ouvriers aujourd'hui tous
les citoyens en moyenne qui ont un
revenu inférieur à à peu près 900 € par
mois ce qui est quand même une part non
négligeable de l'électorat ils votent
plus à gauche les employés ils votent
plus à gauche et ça c'est important de
le rappeler parce que sinon tu prends
une stat sur les ouvriers tu déformes et
tu donnes une vision complètement
déformée du débatrois il faut croiser
avec le revenu il faut croiser avec que
les gens possède est-ce que tu es
propriétaire ou pas c'est quand même
vachement important quand on essaie de
regarder les problèmes de de pouvoir
d'achat il faut il faut cro locataire
non mais bon à Paris c'est c'est
compliqué d'être propriétaire il y a
beaucoup d'autres partis en France où
les gens y arrivent plus mais tout le
monde y arrive pas et donc savoir si on
est propriétaire ou pas on montre que ça
ça compte beaucoup pour essayer
comprendre comprendre le vote de prof
salaire de prof
4000 4000 € ouis non mais
n royalty bouquins ça donne quoi oh les
MI c'est pas
terrible non mais alors moi moi j'ai moi
j'ai j'ai une chance incroyable j'ai
vendu mon capital au 21e siècle et
d'autres livres j'ai fait des millions
d'exemplaires et millionir toi et je
alors moi je je voudrais payer 90 %
d'impôt 95 % d'impôt sur ces droits
d'auteur parce que je pense que quand tu
vend ah non zéro mais les banques
proposent c'est incroyable mais mais si
tu veux moi je moi ça propose à partir
de combien bah il propose tout de suite
dès qu'il vut un peu d'argent il propose
he de tout façon bah j'en sais rien faut
leur demander mais c'est typiquement
s'il sentent qu'il y a des millions dans
l'affaire ça les intéresse donc le le si
tu veux le truc c'est que moi que cette
expérience m'a complètement confirmé
dans ce que je pensais avant mais encore
plus c'est que quand quand tu as la
chancemation ça a pas mis un billet dans
tes recherches non je crois pas parce
que si tu veux moi ce que je vois très
bien c'est quand tu vend c'est ce que tu
te rends compte c'est quand tu vends 3
millions d'exemplair ou 4 millions
d'exemplaires ce qui était le cas pour
le capital au 21e siècle ça veut pas
dire ça veut pas dire ça veut pas dire
que ton bouquin alors je je tiens à dire
que je l' rencontré en 2010 bien avant
il éta pauvre à
l'épque mais attends bon enfin bref
quand quand tu vends 3 millions
d'exemplaires ça veut pas dire que ton
bouquin est 1000 fois mieux queun mec
qui a vendu 3000 exemplaires tu
comprends qu' y a un côté complètement
spécul dans le bouquin comme surtout
c'est que les gens ils suivent un effet
de mode machin truc c'est aussi une
question de B non ça
moi rien du tout je laisse je
lae oui tu donnes un peu
maisit bien sûr mais en même temps moi
ce que je voudrais vraiment c'est c'est
c'est pay c'est payé 95% d'impôt parce
que je pense que au-delà d'un certain
revenu et par de combien moi je pense
que si tu veux un écart de revenu de de
de 1 à 4 ou de 1 à 5 pe peut se
justifier certains diraient 1 à 10 moi
je pense 1 à 5 suffit ce qui est sûr
c'est que les écarts de revenu de 120 ou
de 1,50 ou de 11 100 donc des gens qui
tu veux si tu as bah concrètement si tu
as un salaire minimum qui va être 1000
1500 € par mois tu as pas besoin de gens
qui gagnent 10000 à forceori 20000 50000
100000 tu as juste pas besoin c'est moi
mon travail jusqu'ici quand même ça a
consisté mes travaux de recherche avant
ce bouquin avec Julia sur l'histoire du
vote j'ai regardé l'histoire des écarts
de revenus c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
tout con c'est d'essayer de rassembler
des données historiques sur différentes
sociétés depuis le 19e siècle sur des
dizaines de pays dans le monde sur quels
sont les écarts de revenus de patrimoine
et quels sont les écarts qui qui
permettent ou pas d'avoir de la
croissance du développement économique
et la conclusion générale c'est que ok
tu veux peut-être des écarts de 1 à 5 si
tu avais tout le monde av exactement le
même revenu ça marcherait pas trop mais
que avoir des écarts très élevés de 1 à
50 ou de 1 à 100 ça ne sert à rien tout
simplement c'estàd qu'en fait bon B ça
ça enrichit certaines personnes
particulières mais du point de vue de
l'innovation du point de vue de la
croissance de la prospérité ça ne sert à
rien en face qui est c'est du
nivellement par le bas le fait qu'il a
des grands patrons qui gagnent plein de
blé ça pousse les gens à regarder vers
le ciel d'un point de vue théorique je
non mais non mais d'un point de vue
théorique c'est un argument génial mais
simplement à un moment faut sortir de la
théorie tu vois c'est il faut regarder
ok est-ce que c'est vrai c'estàdire
est-ce que bah par exemple concrètement
des tu avais des écarts gigantesques
dans tous les pays européens parler un
peu ta femme ah ouais mais dans ce CASL
faut poser des questions autes que sur
cette question d'inégalité de revenu on
va parler du financement de la
démocratie on va parler du vote tout
quand as comprimé en un mot quand il y a
une grande compression des écarts de
revenus et de fortune entre 1914 1950
est-ce que ça a tué le développement
économique pas du tout les décennies
d'après-gerre été beaucoup plus
prospères que toutes les autres avant
quand on a remonté les écarts de fortune
à partir des années 80 90 est-ce que
est-ce que ça ça a triplé l'innovation
la croissance du revenu moyen du SAL
moyen pas du tout donc tu vois en
comparant toutes ces périodes
historiques c'est on arrive quand même à
des conclusions après on reste en
sciences sociales et moi je je je là
aussi ma démarche consiste à mettre
toutes les données disponibles pour tout
le monde pour ceux qui veulent pas lire
le livre ou pour ceux qui veulent
compléter le livre avec le le site et
les données et à chacun de voilà de se
faire son opinion moi je pense que les
éléments historiques dont on dispose
sont quand même suffisants pour conclure
que voilà des écarts raisonnables
peuvent se justifier mettons 1 à 5 mais
au-delà au-delà d'un certain S ça sert à
rien mais à chacun d'aller jeter un coup
d'œil au livre au donné et c'est pareil
sur sur sur sur le vote nous notre
démarche c'est d'abord bah d'essayer de
comprendre c'est tu vois tu disais tu
parlais de Macron le vote le plus
bourgeois de l'histoire bon nous c'est
un truc c'est un truc très factuel ouais
mais on va expliquer comment on l'a fait
ouais non parce que c'est pas c'est pas
évident P avant avant avant de
m'expliquer votre méthodologie est-ce
que vous avez remarqué à partir d'une
certaine année les phénomènes de nudge
les phénomènes d'ingérence extérieure
les phénomènes de instrumentalisation de
l'électorat les phénomènes de
subordnation de vote que ce soit par la
gauche ou par la droite que ce soit par
des puissances étrangères béliqueuses
est-ce que vous avez vu des choses comme
ça bah là tu tu mets à peu près 22
sujets dans dans dans la même question
donc on est obligé de dire oui il y a
des trucs qu'on a vu moi non mais je
sais pas si on parle sur la question du
du du vote par exemple il y a un truc
qui est quand même vraiment frappant au
cours des des dernières années qui qui
joue un rôle croissant en France qu'on a
vu beaucoup dans la politique
états-unienne pour le coup c'est c'est
le rôle de l'argent privé dans dans dans
la vie politique tu prends le cas des
États-Unis en fait jusqu'en 2008 tu as
encore un système qui s'appelle le
présidential fond le fond présidentiel
où les candidats en fait à la
présidentielle américaine prennent un
financement public refusent les dons
privés et du coup tu as les dépenses de
campagne qui sont à peu près capées
autour de 2008 quand Obama est le
premier à refuser ça on est à 84
millions de dollars il se trouve qu'en
2008 Obama c'est le premier à refuser le
financement public ouais en fait 84
millions en France c'est 22 millions
d'euros les dépenses de 2è tour pour un
candid candidat à la présidentielle
normalisé par la population on est à peu
près dans le même ordre de de grandeur
et Obama dit bah non en fait je vais pas
prendre 84 millions de dollars de de
financement pr de public je préfère
dépenser plus avec de l'argent privé il
met à mal en fait ce système de fonds
présidentiel 2012 du coup tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle le
le font 2016 tous les candidats au
primaires le font aux États-Unis
c'estàdire même Bernie Sanders et c'est
un tout petit peu triste quand tu vois
que même Bernie Sanders qui dénonce le
rôle de l'argent privé aux États-Unis
bah en fait c'est ça ouais alors ça
c'est un peu une caricature mais oui
c'est le gentil il fait Frid voilà c'est
très joli c'est pas par c'est très joli
mais il neige il fait froid ou mais il
avait des moufles à Washington en
l'occurrence c'était pour l'inauguration
mais il fait il fait tomber on peut pas
parler sérieusement en fait il il fait
tomber le système de de financement
public y compris pour les primaires et
tu prends le dernier cycle électoral aux
États-Unis on a 4 milliards de dépenses
et en fait on est à 4 milliards sans
financement public et tu as des gens
comme les frères coqu aux États-Unis qui
disent et qui font on peut dépenser 1
milliards de dollars par cycle électoral
là aussi d'ailleurs on voit le l'effet
des inégalités économiques c'estàd qu'à
un moment donné avant on pouvait pas
dépenser un milliard de dollars par
cycle électoral pourquoi en fait parce
que tu avais pas de de gens qui avaient
un milliard de cash comme ça à cramer
pour des élections maintenant avec
l'explosion des inégalités tu l'as je
sais pas si tu appellees ça la
subordination de vote et ceteranation
subornation de vote mais ça vient
complètement déformer finalement le
prisme électoral et je pense que ça
explique aussi en partie la chute de la
participation politique parce que les
plus modestes du coup ils s'interrogent
sur bah le l'effet de leur vote dans un
système où ils ont l'impression que le
jeu démocratique est en partie capturé
et par rapport à ça il y a quand même un
point que que que que je veux souligner
c'est que cette explosion des inégalités
tu le vois aussi dans les les
patrimoines des plus gros milliardaires
avec des conséquences concrètes tu prend
le prix de rachat de Twitter par musk si
je me trompe pas c'est autour de 4
milliards de dollars à peu près 40
milliards de dollars pardon exactement
ce que économiste ouais l' économiste
moi j'oublie les zéros c'est autour de
de 40 milliards de dollars décation che
vous ça pour le coup c'est vraiment moi
je suis nulle avec tout ça je déteste la
paperass je suis vraiment le j'adore toi
tuadores pas mais tu as pas le choix
paril faut bien les déclarer donc c'est
c'est désolé d'avoir coupé non mais du
coup 40 milliards et en fait si tu
regardes il y encore 10 ans même Bill
Gates en fait il l'aurais pas pu acheter
Twitter puce qu'il avait pas 40
milliards de cash libre et ça montre
aussi un autre truc en plus de l'effet
de cet explosion qui per différence
quand tu as 200 tu peux tu peux dépenser
40 sans t'en rendre compte ou alors que
quand tu as 10 tu peux pas mais du du
coup ça a deux conséquences concrètes
c'est veut dire que tu as un type qui
peut tuer un réseau social en l'espace
d'un an c'est pas simplement le le
renommé bah parce que les gens alors je
dis pas ça pour anidalgo sa déclaration
d'hier ça c'est un tout petit peu
anecdotiqueidalgo c'est qui c'est la
merè de Paris oui les bouchons non je
rigole c'est la mè de Paris mais qui a
annoncé hier qu'elle quittait Twitter
qu'elle quittait x bon voilà et c'est la
première fois enfin en France c'est le
premier gros départ d'un politique mais
en l'occurrence tu regardes le trafic tu
regardes les les les abonnements sur
Twitter tu regardes les engagements sur
Twitter ça s'est effondré depuis le
rachat par musk 1 et deuxièmement tu
regardes la ah si si si si si ah bah tu
regardes les stades de Twitter ça a
diminué tu as la visibilité qui a changé
tu as tout le système d'abonnement
maintenant faut payer pour avoir un
badget bleu avant c'était quand même
davantage de lisibilité tu as des gens
qui travaillent quand même sur ces
sujets enfin d'ailleurs tu as de moins
en moins de gens qui travaillent sur ces
sujets alors ça ça préoccupe peut-être
que moi mais tu vois il y avait un truc
qui s'appelait laap Twitter qui
permettait à des chercheurs d'étudier
les contenus sur Twitter ils ont fait
tomber la pay Twitter tu peux même plus
étudier des contenus sur Twitter mais
ferm-m la parenthèse même si ça marchait
mieux en tout cas il en a changé la
ligne il a décidé tout seul de
réintroduire certains comptes par
exemple le le compte de de Donald Trump
et d'autres mais tu vois tu as donc tu
as ce tu as ce premier truc quand même
avec les inégalités et puis le deuxième
truc c'est que tu as souvent un argument
qui est utilisé alors en France c'est
pas utilisé tellement sur musk mais
plutôt sur Bernard Arnaud quand on va
dire bah ouais son patrimoine a explosé
regardez ça a monté il y a plein de gens
qui disent c'est pas du vrai argent
parce qu'en fait c'est pas du cash qu'il
a sur son compte en banque c'est la
valeur des actions mais fait ce que
montre musk c'est que c'est du vrai
argent je veux dire musk il avait pas 40
milliards sur son compte en banque il
avait des actions Tesla et quand il veut
les utiliser il fait
quoi et du coupud le montage financier
Mo ça je m'en fous complètement de son
montage financier mais mais non mais tu
vois c'est important de dire que c'est
du vrai argent ça donne un vrai pouvoir
c'estàd que les gens qui prétendent que
c'est pas vraiment l'argent de Bernard
Arnaud c'est pas parce qu'on a des
variations dans son cours en Bourse
qu'on peut direan central sont
responsables de
çaah elles ont plutôt contribué à
enrichir
les plus riches effectivement ell
auraient pu bah parce que quand tu quand
tu injectes comme ça autant de de de
liquidité les les prix boursiers les
prix immobiliers ça ça contribue à les
faire monter et quand alors tu me diras
tu as des taux d'intérêt très faibles tu
peux en principe tu peux tout le monde
peut s'endetter bon sauf que quand tu as
une grosse mise de départ tu as un effet
de levier tu peux t'endetter très
fortement et au total bah on voit très
bien au moment de la crise de 2008 les
les plus riches du monde étaient à 30 40
là les plus riches du monde sont à 200
250 tu vois bien que la taille de
l'économie mondiale elle a pas progressé
à ce rythme là don donc c'est bien enfin
je ve dire le fait d'avoir des riches
des pauvres jusqu'à un certain point ça
peut se justifier mais il faut que les
écarts restent raisonnaables c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure puis il faut
que tout ça progresse à peu près au même
rythme c'est si le sommet progresse tro
quatre fois plus vite que la taille de
l'économie mondiale tu tu vois bien
qu'il y a un problème c'est ça peut pas
continuer comme ça comme ça indéfiniment
et là en l'occurence les les politiques
de sauvetage des banques du secteur
financier de l'économie en général après
2008 après 2020 à la fois c'était mieux
que de tout laisser s'effondrer comme
dans les années 30 donc ça on a appris
là-dessus mais à un moment il y aurait
quand même fallu faire payer Bern
comment tu es un disciple de ben bernan
oui non mais lui-même est un disciple de
de de de de la faillite pendant la crise
des années 30 c'est tout le monde a
constaté que pant la crise des années 30
l'orthodoxie monétaire ça ça avait amené
le monde au bord du goufre et même
direct dans le goufre là c'est pas
renculé pour mieux sauter alors c'est ça
le problème c'est que si on fait que ça
c'est si on ne fait que sauver le le
capitalisme privé le le secteur
financier sans ensuite par derrière bah
demander des comptes quand même à ceux
qu'on fait des conneries et puis faire
payer l'addition tu vois là ça va ça ça
va pas du tout donc ça c'est ça le c'est
ça le gros problème mais sur sur quand
même cette ça peut se matérialiser quand
on injecte trop de liquidité bah il y a
un moment tu as de l'inflation he ça
c'est le qu'on a là de toute façon ça
c'est clair à un moment de toute façon
quelqu'un pay avec les milliers de
milliards qu'on a injecté que ce soit en
Europe aux États-Unis ou
ailleurs tu penses qu'on est au début de
l'inflation au milieu de l'inflation à
la fin de l'inflation bah là on a eu 2 3
ans bonne inflation et et qui ont
commencé bah là tu vois on est passé
auudessus de 10 % ce qu'on avait pas vu
depuis les début des années 80 ce qu'on
avait pas vu depuis 40 ans enfin dans
les dans les pays riches je veux dire
donc donc ça c'est vraiment nouveau et
concrètement bah quand tu as une
inflation à 10 % tu vois c'est c'est un
impôt de 10 % sur l'épargne de 10000 €
tu vois le le type qui a bossé dur qui a
à peine épargné 10000 50000 100000 €
avec son salaire il se prend 10 % alors
que le mec qui a des milliards lui il il
place tout ça il continue de faire des
très bonnes affaires donc on a a eu un
impôt sur les petits patrimoines un
impôt très régressif pour faire payer
finalement la la création monétaire qui
a sauvé les les banquiers de l'autre
côté donc là il y a il y a un moment ça
ça déconne complètement mais ce que je
voulais ajouter à ce que à ce que dit
Julia c'est que c'est ces phénomènes de
découragement des électeurs face à
l'emprise de l'argent sur la politique
c'est à la fois très réel et en même
temps ça peut aussi permettre la
mobilisation c'estàdire que si on
remonte euh tu vois au début du 20e
siècle au 19e siècle parce que nous on a
cette cette perspective historique ce
qu'on constate c'est que des périodes de
très fortes inégalités ça peut aussi
conduire à la à la à des mobilisations
politiques on regarde tu vois les
élections en 1848 tokville il amène ses
ses ses paysans vootés pour lui pour le
faire élire bon c'est phénomènes
d'emprise ça pas d'ailleurs il en est il
en est très c'est ça qui est trop drôle
toville l'écrit il pourrait avoir honte
il pourrait le faire de manière cachée
aujourd'hui et lui il décrit ben oui moi
et tous mes paysans derrière moi on
monte jusqu'en haut de la montagne je
les amène au bureau de vote et
d'ailleurs personne il dit person
personne ne demande pour qui ils ont
voté tellement c'est évident donc c'est
un truc de fou c'est une tu demandais
des exemples de manipulation électorale
jusqu'à 1914 on a plein de scrutins qui
sont invalidés suite à des plaintes
parce que il y a eu des pressions des
propriétaires fonciers notamment auprès
de leur leur paysans des curés aussi qui
en pleine dans l'église et alors ça ça
soloire obligatoire ça commence en 1913
et c'est vrai qu'à partir de l'entre de
guerre disons en tout cas ce qu'on
observe c'est que le nombre de plaintes
pour pour demander l'invalidation de
résultat C manipulation 10 minutes ça
veut pas dire qu'il y a plus de
manipulation mais en tout cas ça ça
donne lieu à moins de contestation et
ces pratique semble un peu se se
diminuer après tu as une autre forme
d'influence qui est celle que décrivait
Julia qui est à travers la la propriété
des médias à travers l'influence que tu
as en finançant des S tank qui sont
quand même biaisés d'une certaine façon
donc voilà tuas tu as d'autres façons
d'influer sur le sur le processus et
nous notre analyse dans le livre c'est
que c'est c'est ça fait partie de
l'explication pour cet effondrement de
la la participation et donc ça c'est
quand même un énorme souci parce que
pendant longtemps sont pas si con que ça
en fait ah ben non les gens s'en
aperçoivent bien et d'une certaine
manière enfin pour le coup c'est
l'avantage entre guillemets de ce qui
s'est passé avec Macron en 2017 pour la
première fois ça l'a rendu vraiment
visible c'est-à-dire cette question du
financement privé de la démocratie en
France tu en parles à intervalle
régulier quand tu as des scandales tu as
l'affaire Urba dans la fin des années
1980 ce qui fait qu'on a la mise en
place d'un encadrement en 1988 1990 la
mise en place d'un financement public tu
as encore quelques scandales du coup 19
95 on interdit quand même le don des
entreprises mais après c'est un truc qui
est un peu sous le tapis sous la table
et personne ne parle V des dons privés
même on subventionne subvention
énormément les dons privés aujourd'hui
en France si tu fais partie des Français
les plus riches que tu donnes 7500 € à
un parti politique l'état te rembourse
5000 € c'est-à-dire en fait tu as les 2
tiers de tes préférences politiques qui
sont subventionnées financièrement par
l'État tu fais partie de par le reste
des contribbles 50 % des Français les
plus pauvres donc en gros tu payes
beaucoup d'impô tu PES ta CSG tu PES ta
TVA tu PES ta taxe frontière tu PES ta
taxe d'habitation tu PES tous tes impôts
c'est juste que tu as un taux marginal
d'imposition sur le revenu qui est égal
à zé parce que tu as un petit revenu
dans ce cas-là tu donnes 120 € à un
parti politique ou 120 € d'ailleurs à
une association tu paies 120 € parce que
comme tu es pas imposable au titre de
l'impôt sur le revenu tu ne bénéficies
pas des réductions d'impôt donc on a ce
système complètement fou où c'est vrai
on fait payer en fait les plus pauvres
pour subventionner les préférences
politiques des plus riches et ça je veux
dire
au niveau des dons philanthropiques des
dons aux associations c'est à peu près
le cas partout sauf pas avec des des
financements aussi gros sur les dons
politique tu as ça en France tu as un
peu ça en Allemagne mais tu as quand
même plein de pays où c'est pas le cas
tu vois où les pays se sont interrogés
ils sont dit est-ce qu'il faut
subventionner avec de l'argent publi les
dons politiques et la réponse ça a été
non en France on le fait à hauteur de
2/3 d'ailleurs de 2/3 sur les dons aux
associations pour les contribuables
ancien ISF maintenant les contribuables
IFI les dons aux associations ils sont
subventionnés à hauteur des 3/4
alors tu files un don à une association
mais quand je dis une association encore
ça au resto du cœur ça va ou à la Croix
Rouge mais tu donnes de 100000 € à l'App
par exemple je donne l'exemple de l'AP
parce que j'adore l'ifapp parce que l'AP
c'est un S tank très marqué à droite
complètement anti-état tu tu vas sur le
site de de de voilà non mais c'est ça le
truc qui est trop drôle tu vas sur le
site
deapppp non non mais si j'ai pas fini
sur l' frapp tu vois sur le site de l'
frapp en général ils disent il faut
moins d'État MOS d'éco publ c'est
complètement oui s qu'en fait en même
temps ils ont un énorme bandeau qui dit
donner àifapp et bénéficier de 75 % de
réduction d'impôts donc ils sont très
contents par contre que si tu donnes à
l'rapp tu as 75 % d'argent public mais
par contre pour l'école ils le veulent
pasah il pourra militer contre cette
législation si public sont contre l'État
et contre les impôs on vous laissera
régler ce discours avec frapp
directement pas mais le fait qu'en 2017
Julien
disait
plus non mais vas-y fais fais 2017 moi
je ferai Le Vot le plus beaujois de
l'histoire j'aimerais bien revenir quand
même à un moment donné Emmanuel Macron a
reçoit plus de dons à Londres que dans
toutes les villes de province réunies
euh ça ça c'est difficile de penser que
ça n'a aucun effet sur les sens des
priorités c'estàdire que ces questions
de financement ont ont un effet sur le
sens des priorités après nous ce qu'on
ce sur quoi on insiste quand même dans
le livre c'est que au-delà de ces
questions de de financement de
manipulation et cetera il y a quand même
des enjeux de fond qui détermine les
éleation c'est légal
c'est-à-dire c'est légal mais ça donne
pas le poids le le même poids à chaque
CIT c'est ça qui est complètement
frappant tu vois en fait ça serait pas
un problème en soi d'avoir ces
financements privés qui sont
complètement légaux encore une fois
c'est pas des dessous de table c'est pas
kadfi c'est pas Sarkozi machin c'est
complètement légal sauf que quand tu
regardes les données qu'est-ce que tu
vois tu vois que c'est pas tous les
Français qui ont la même probabilité de
faire un don de 100 € c'est qu'en
moyenne tu as moins de 1 % des Français
qui donnent si tu prends parmi ça c'est
les données fiscales tu monde à ber
c'est les données fiscales c'est publ on
les a mis en ligne avec le prix de la
démocratie parmi les 0,01 % des Français
les plus riches c'est pas moins de 1 %
de donateurs c'est plus de 12 % de
donateurs tu regardes le don moyen parmi
les gens qui donnent c'est en moyenne
120 € sur l'ensemble de la distribution
tu prends parmi les 0,01 % des Français
les plus riches c'est plus de 5500 € de
Don moyen et d'ailleurs tu es content
d'avoir un plafond à 7005 parce que
sinon ça veut dire que ça serait
au-dessus et du coup à l'arrivée tu as
même pas 10 % des Français qui
représentent plus de 70 % des dons et
quand je dis ces dons ces cotisations
adhésion au parti politique donc c'est
un système légal mais c'est un système
qui est mal ficelé parce qu' donne trop
d'importance beaucoup plus d'importance
au plus riche qu'au plus modeste dans le
débat public c'est comme si je te disais
et tu ça a été légal pendant un certain
temps tu prends tout la fin du 19e
siècle début du 20e siècle dans dans
dans l'histoire électorale suédoise tu
avais un système tout à fait légal où le
nombre de droits de vote variait avec le
revenu et le patrimoine et donc en fait
plus les gens avaient des revenus élevés
c'était même pas un suffrage sansitaire
cétait même pas le truc complètement
binaire les plus pauvres gagnent pas
assez peuvent pas voter les plus riches
peuvent voter là tu avais plus de droit
de vote c'est plus d'argent bon fait
jusque entre 1 et 100 votes bon fallait
faire partie des 20 % les plus riches
pour voter tu avais il connait mieux ça
précise parce que tu as aussi le truc
des entreprises qui pouvit V les
entreprises ont le droit de vote aux
élections municipales en Suède jusqu'en
1910 et et toujours avec un nombre de
droit de vote qui dépend
proportionnellement du capital que tu as
installé dans et tu as plusieurs de
dizaines de de de municipalités en Suède
où un seul électeur à plus de 50 % des
droits de vote et donc il est un
dictateur de façon parfaitement légale
donc voilà tout ça pour dire que la
légalité ça peut prendre différentes
formes et et que parce que c'est légal
que c'est bien c'est pareil pour les
financement pr tout ça ça a été des
luttes énormes pour changer ce système
institutionnel à nouveau des
mobilisations sociales les syndicats le
parti socialdémocrate qui prend le
pouvoir en Suède en 1932 et qui change
totalement mais totalement ça n'a rien à
voir avec des des socio-démocrates mou
dont on pourrait parler aujourd'hui il
te change le système institutionnel avec
en mettant en place un système
d'éducation de santé qui est peut-être
pas parfait mais qui est qui était plus
égalitaire et plus ouvert et plus
inclusif que tout ce qu'on avait vu
jusque là en partant d'un pays qui était
l'un des plus inégalitair et les plus
sophistiqués dans l'organisation de du
de du du pouvoir politique en fonction
de de l'argent c'est c'est dire si tout
ça pe peut changer et et en France aussi
ça ça ça a beaucoup changé juliaen tu
veux ajouter un mot bah si je peux faire
le vote Macron est-il le plus bourgeois
de l'histoire c'est pas le bon moment
encore faistoi plaisir FAA non mais si
c'est c'est une manière d'expliquer ce
qu'on fait dans le livre pourquoi c'est
utile et pourquoi c'est clair également
les qu'on sur les banques centrales
qu'on fasse un peu de géopo on fera les
on fera les banques mais en fait c'est
quand même lié hein je veux dire les les
politiques économiques qui sont mis en U
si on comprend pas la structure de
l'électorat on passe quand même à côté
de de quelque chose il y a un truc qu'on
fait dans le livre c'est la chose
suivante depuis 1789 pour chacune des
communes on va collecter des données sur
le niveau d'éducation le niveau de de de
diplôme la population et puis le niveau
de richesse depuis 1789 on a
l'équivalent de la taxe foncière
aujourd'hui donc on a une une vision
assez claire en fait par commune par
année de l'évolution du capital
immobilier c'est c'est pareil sur les
revenus ça nous permet de faire quoi bah
ça nous permet de classer finalement
toutes les communes par percentile de de
revenus des 1 % des communes les plus
pauvres après le 2ème pourcentile le 3è
jusqu'au 10 % des communes les plus
riches et 5 % des communes les plus
riches les 1 % des communes les plus
riches et du coup ensuite
systématiquement pour chacune des
élections tu peux regarder comment a
voté la commune pour tel ou tel candidat
par rapport au au au score moyen obtenu
par le candidat bon tu prends 2022 le
vote ensemble donc le vote Macron au
législative qu'est-ce qu'on voit on voit
que Macron obtient en moyenne 1,7 fois
plus de de de de de VO de voix dans les
1 % des communes les les les plus riches
comme moyenne nationale et si tu
regardes la courbe je peux pas montrer
une courbe à l'écran la courbe elle est
croissante comme ça entre le le le
revenu de la commune et le vote Macron
et ça monte très très fort donc c'est un
vote qui décolle vraiment dans les 10 5
1 % des communes les plus riches ça
c'est pas exactement exponentiel mais ça
augmente quand même relativement
rapidement ça c'est un truc qui est pas
propre uniquement à emmanuell Macron
c'est quelque chose qu'on constate pour
la plupart des votes de droite
traditionnel ça ressemble assez bien en
fait à la structure du vote giscar la
structure du vote baladure la structure
du vote Chirac et cetera et cetera mais
tu as une caractéristique du vote Macron
qui est vraiment frappante c'est ce qui
se passe en bas de la distribution dans
les 70 % des communes les plus pauvres
Macron est en dessous de sa sa moyenne
nationale et ça c'est pas quelque chose
que tu avais historiquement parce que la
droite traditionnel était capable
d'aller convaincre une partie de
l'électorat en ruralité et ça Macron il
a pas du tout cet électorat là ce qui
fait qu'il a une base électorale
extrêmement étroite et extrêmement
favorisée et c'est ça aussi quand on
regarde l'effondrement de la
participation c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment donné les plus modestes s'il voit
que tu as un un vote Macron qui peut se
maintenir au pouvoir avec 30 % des voix
qui peut faire passer finalement la
réforme des retraites contre 75 % de la
population malgré des manifestations qui
en comparé raisons historiques on avait
rien eu de tel depuis 1995 bah ça
décourage de se mobiliser ça décourage
de participer ça a des conséquences du
coup très très clair sur la structure de
l'électorat et aussi sur les politiques
ensuite qui sont mises en œuvre par par
par Emmanuel Macron par son gouvernement
et puis plus largement si on parle des
banques centrales il faut pas parler de
la France il faut parler au niveau de au
niveau de l'Union européenne mais le
fait d'avoir un vote très bourgeois non
je la prends je je crois que céit le
principe mais le fait d'avoir un vote
très bourgeois ça veut pas dire qu'on a
forcément tur je veux dire c'est pas le
fait de non mais soyons clair nous on on
n pas de problème avec ça le fait de
s'appuyer davantage sur des personnes
qui ont eu du succès sur le plan
économique après tout ça peut venir avec
des expériences des choses à apporter à
la à la table de la délibération
démocratique donc en soi c'est pas une
tare d'avoir un vote plus bourgeois que
les autres là le problème qu'on a sur le
sur le vote Macron c'est d'abord que la
pente est quand même c'est vrai
exceptionnellement forte c'estàdire
qu'on a une pente qui est encore plus
forte disons que giscar que Sarkozi que
baladure donc il y a un moment disons le
risque c'est de s'habituer à avoir
raison tout seul quoi et ça c'est il y a
un moment ça c'est donc quand la pente
est vraiment trop forte ça peut être
embêtant mais surtout le le second
problème qui qui est plus grave encore
et ça façon c'est pas de la faute de
Macron c'est que les classes populaires
donc l'élector inverse est sont divisés
en gros entre les classes populaires
plus rurales ou des petites villes et
les classes populaires urbaines et des
métropoles et c'est ça qui fait que les
deux oppositions à Macron en gros le le
bloc de gauche plutôt populaire urbain
et le et le bloc de droite plutôt
populaire et des petites villes ou en
ruralité en fait s'annule l'un l'autre
et et et et Macron peut continuer comme
disait Julia de se maintenir au pouvoir
et d'avoir une politique même si il a 70
% contre lui parce qu'il se dit de toute
façon les deux oppositions sont divisées
et ça ce que montre notre notre analyse
historique c'est que ça s'est déjà
produit ce genre de division des classes
populaires rurales et urbaines fin 19e
siècle on avait un peu la même situation
au début de la 3e république on avait un
groupe un peu au centre un peu comme le
groupe macronien aujourd'hui qu'on
appelait à l'époque les républicains
modérés les républicains opportunistes
avec à sa gauche des socialistes
radicaux socialistes et à sa droite des
groupes
conservateur catholique monarchiste qui
vont ensuite se rallier à la République
devenir la droite et ce système
finalement s'est révélé très instable
c'est-à-dire que à la fin des fins ce ce
système qui était déjà un peu de
tripartition comme aujourd'hui s'est
effondré en pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que le le groupe central à
l'époque les républicains opportunistes
étai très favorisé socialement et ça a
fini par cevoir ce qui est un peu le cas
aujourd'hui avec le bloc Macron c'est
que ça finit par se voir quand même
qu'on a un électorat aussi bourgeois et
ça finit par par créer des contestations
et et et pour se maintenir au pouvoir il
faut soit s'allier vers la gauche ou
vers la droite actuellement plutôt vers
la droite comme on le voit actuellement
avec la la loi immigration il y a S plus
de proximité avec avec les républicains
et voire avec une partie du du du
rassemblement national qui est plus qui
est plus proche du libéralisme
économique et et donc c'est ça c'est la
première raison pour laquelle le système
de de tripartition fin 19e siècle début
20e siècle s'est effondré la deuxième
raison c'est aussi que les parties de
gauche ont été chercher les électeurs
dans les territoires ruraux dans les
petites villes et finalement pendant une
grande partie du 20e siècle la la
division entre le monde urbain le monde
rural est atténuée c'estàdire si on
prend un vote comme mitteran en 81 en
fait il a pratiquement le même score
dans les villages les bourgs et dans les
banlieux les métropoles et donc la
gauche a réussi pendant une grande
partie du 20e siècle à convaincre les
classes populaires urbaines et rurales
que finalement ce qui les divise est
moins important que ce qui les rassemble
et c'est un peu le même enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est un peu ce que
quelqu'un comme François Ruffin va
essayer de faire dans la Somme dans sa
circonscription en essayant de faire
voter les les classes populaires des
petites villes des bourgs et les classes
populaires des des banlieux ensemble
nous on dit pas du tout que c'est facile
mais mais ce qu'on dit c'est que si on
veut sortir de la tripartition actuelle
avec l'absence d'alternance politique
que ça implique et bien faut essayer de
revenir sur ces leçons de l'histoire
faut essayer effectivement de rapprocher
ces ces des classes populaires de
différents territoires il faut essayer
de faire en sorte que le clivage social
finement l'emporte sur le clivage
territorial c'est que quand les
divisions territoriales sont trop
importantes ça bloque un peu
l'alternance politique donc pour résumer
le problème c'est pas tant le vote
bourgeois de Macron parce qu'après tout
il y a toujours eu des votes bourgeois
dans l'histoire et c'est c'est
parfaitement légitime c'est le fait que
comme le vote populaire lui n'est pas
unifié et très divisé bah le système est
bloqué ça empêche ça ça empêche
l'alternance et et donc c'est c'est
c'est de ce côté-là qu'il faut imaginer
la sortie bonsoir vous affirmez que les
inégalités les inégalités ont énormément
augmenté pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît
préciser le point de départ que vous
prenez l'abolition de l'esclavage la fin
du
servage euh non non quand on dit
qu'elles ont augmenté elles ont
réaugmenté depuis 1980 en fait d'une
certaine manière c'était ça aussi le
rappel par rapport à 1789 on a eu tout
au long notamment tout tout au long du
20e siècle une grande réduction des
inégalités favorisé par les deux guerres
mondiales les destructions de patrimoine
favorisé aussi par la la mise en place
d'une fiscalité progressive
l'introduction de l'impôt sur le revenu
en France en 1914 le développement de
l'État social l'éducation publique la
santé publique et cetera et cetera et en
fait ça s'inverse autour des années 1980
à différents moments dans différents
endroits enfin c'est le virage réganien
aux États-Unis c'est le virage sacherien
je prononce pas bien euh pardon non
matur margarette ouais margarte ouais au
Royaume-Uni ça se joue aussi en France
où tout d'un coup il y a un virage
libéral qui fait que c'est cette
réduction des inégalités en fait elle va
s'inverser et que si on prend
aujourd'hui par rapport à 1980
l'augmentation des inégalités de de de
de de de patrimoine et et de revenus en
fait ça s'est réaccéléré et ce qui est
vraiment frappant pour le coup vous avez
publié non il y a quelques jours les les
les les chiffres avec le World
inequality Lab c'est de voir
l'augmentation du total des revenus par
les 1 % les les les les plus riches en
France depuis l'élection de Macron en
2017 j'ai pas vérifié mes chiffres mais
toi tu les connais ça augmenté fortement
mais en même temps je veux quand même
augmenté fort genre grosse bamboche ou
ça augmenté fortement petite bamboche
non plutôt plutôt très gros c'estd que
là les derniers chiffres en 2021 2022 si
on prend la part des 1 % les plus riches
dans le revenu total là on est on est
passé à 13 13 14 % ce qui pour 1 % de la
population est quand même beaucoup et on
avait pas vu ça depuis l'entre de guerre
en gros c'est c'est le plus haut niveau
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale et on
est-ce que ça sent la guerre non non non
c'est pas ça que je veux dire du tout là
là on n'est pas c'est pas c'est là c'est
pas ça l'U mais je veux je veux quand
même dire que malgré cette
réaugmentation des inégalités depuis les
les les années 80 90 sur certains plans
on reste aujourd'hui une société
beaucoup plus égalitaire qu'il a un
siècle donc par rapport à l'internaute
qui disait par rapport à l'abolition de
l'esclavage par rapport à la Révolution
française par rapport au servage il y a
un mouvement de long terme vers
l'égalité qui reste extrêmement puissant
et et personne aujourd'hui ni Macron ni
personne ne va supprimer la sécurité
sociale alors il peut restreindre les
dépenses sur les retraites plus qu'il
faudrait mais on va pas revenir au point
de départ enfin concrètement aujourd'hui
dans en France comme dans la plupart des
pays d'Europe occidentale on va mettre
en commun entre 40 et 50 % du revenu
national pour payer un système d'État
social d'éducation de santé de de de
retraite avant la Première Guerre
mondiale c'était moins de 10 % du R
national qui était socialisé sous forme
de de prélèvement en commun personne
aujourd'hui ne va revenir à ce système-
làà c'est l'enjeu non l'enjeu c'est
est-ce qu'on s'arrête là où on dit on ne
peut plus rien financer en plus ce qui
pour nous pose problème parce qu'à
partir du moment où il y a des progrès
dans la santé il y a un vieillissement
de la population si vous voulez bloquer
complètement les dépenses de santé par
exemple au même pourcentage du revenu
national qu'il y a 20 ans bah ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que vu que dans
l'hôpital vous avez forcément plus de
dépenses avec le vieillissement avec les
proets technologiques bah sur la
médecine de ville vous avez moins de
généraliste aujourd'hui ça devent
c'est un super bon enfin c'est un truc
qui est extrêmement frappant c'estàd que
si demain tu sort dans la rue et on
interroge les gens les gens vont dire
qu'en moyen on dépense moins pour la
santé d'argent public aujourd'hui qu'il
y a 5 ou 10 an ce qui est pas vrai en
fait en pourcentage du PIB on dépense
toujours autant pour la santé
aujourd'hui qu'il y a 5 ou 10 ans sauf
qu'en fait ça coûte plus cher les gens
sont plus vieux tant mieux d'ailleurs
ils meurent plus tard tant mieux aussi
de maladies plus rares qu'on soine mieux
tant mieux on a des progrès dans plein
de
de domaines différents et c'est tant
mieux sauf que ça coûte plus cher donc à
un moment donné quand il y a tous les
analystes économistes pseudo expert qui
disent oh là là 50 % du PIB en dépenses
publiqu on peut pas aller plus loin bah
il faut qu'ils nous explique donc en
fait ils sont pour une dégradation de la
médecine de ville de l'hôpital public ou
qu'on arrête le progrs technique pense
qu' vont dire privé ou pour un système
privé aux États-Unis la santé au total
maintenant c'est pratiquement 20 % du pb
pendant longtemps disait la santé c'est
10 % du P on est presque à 20 % au
ÉtatsUnis et ça va continuer de monter
est-ce que ça marche mieux avec le
système privé bah c'est pas clair ça
coûte plus cher et l'espérance de vie
est plus faible donc à la fin des fins
voilà dites-nous comment vous voulez
faire et sur l'éducation sur les
universités c'est pareil c'estd si on
bloque la la dépense publique ce qu'on a
fait en pourcentage de du revenu
national ou du PIB depuis 20 30 ans en
France ou dans d'autres pays européens
comme dans le même temps le pourcentage
d'une classe d'âge qui va à
l'enseignement supérieur était de 20 %
dans les années 80 et aujourd'hui de 50
60 % et tant mieux on va pas revenir
avec un syè me où il y a que 20 % de la
population qui va dans l'enseignement
supérieur mais si les dépenses elles
sont sont figées bah forcément ça veut
dire qu'il y a plein de gens qui vont
s'entasser dans des amphis et finalement
c'est un gâi pour des personnes qui ont
travaillé dur qui voudraent avoir des
places en IUT qui se retrouvent dans une
filière générale qui correspond pas
forcément donc c'est c'est un gâi pour
pour pour tout le monde donc pour
résumer le débat aujourd'hui c'est
est-ce qu'on continue de figer le le
niveau de de de dépens publique ce qui
un peu ce qu'on a fait depuis les années
80 90 est-ce qu'on essaie de de repartir
dans un mouvement à la hausse ce qui
veut dire plus de justice fiscale parce
que si vous faites ça en matraquant les
classes moyennes les classes populaires
évidemment ça va pas marcher donc il
faut il faut mettre à contribution bah
ceux qu'on ceux qu' ont plus de moyens
que les autres c'est c'est un processus
graduel ça a pris un siècle pour passer
du système où il y avait aucun état
social au système qu'on a aujourd'hui
mais nous notre vision c'est que ce
processus il va pas s'arrêter là
c'estàdire que l'idée que le le voilà le
système actuel est figé et qu'on peut
plus rien changer mais en tout cas on va
pas revenir en arrière
tu permett poser une question ou Jul
est-ce que dans votre bouquin ou dans
vos études ou dans votre étude
historique vous avez ajouté la
consommation énergétique avec le vote
est-ce que vous avez ajouté l'accès à
l'énergie ou à la calorie
facile enfin faut regarder les les
variables qu'on Thas tu as quel âge bah
écoute 52 hein et et quand tu es né la
France en fait tu voulais pas que moi je
réponde c'est pas grave tu as dit toi
Jul mais donc il est 71 vasy continue 84
oui bah ça va on sair 40 ans bientôt
c'est pas encore 39 là ça va je suis
sous
làbas non c'est quand tu es né on
consommait combien de millions de barils
par jour en France ah j'en sais rien moi
mais mais bon beaucoup est-ce est-ce que
tu comprends l'interconnexion entre
avancée sociale consommation énergétique
et on va dire épiphénomène
démocratique est-ce que que là on voit
les banques centrales arroser d'argent
magique les tout big tout fail arroser
tout le monde d'argent magique avec le
covid arroser tout le monde mais la
réalité énergétique de ta monnaie elle
en est où est-ce que ton progrès social
ton avancée sociale ton machin était pas
en fait Coré à ta consommation
énergétique alors pour résumer très
d'une façon très très triviale quand il
y a plus de foin dans les ateliers les
Chau se Batt donc est-ce que ton prisme
de lecture basé sur l'émancipation le
progrès la santé on dirait que tu aimes
pas ça nipation ni le progrès ni la
santé j'adore ça j'adore ça mais en fait
quand je vois l'inflation je me dis que
il y a peut-être un problème
attend' merci tu es bien gentil tu es
bien
magnanime est-ce que quand tu vois ça et
que il y a des restrictions énergétiques
que les SA commence à s'intéresser au
nucléaire que avec la guerre en Ukraine
tout de suite on voit que le le le
système est overstetch que il déploie
des trésors d'ingéniosité pour éviter
qu'on se rende compte que le pétrole
russe passe par l'Inde et que bon les
Indiens se prenent prennent une petite
commission mais en gros sans énergie pas
de progrès sans énergie inflation sans
énergie maintenir ce fameux rêve oui
mais là tu vois donc la question que je
me pose c'est plus il y a d'énergie plus
il y a de progrès social moins il y a
d'énergie moins a de progrè mais attends
là tu fais comme si tout le monde avait
la même consommation d'énergie mais
c'est pas du tout ça la situation dans
lequelle on est bon alors entre le Sud
et le Nord tu tu as compris la
différence mais à l'intérieur de chaque
pays à l'intérieur du Sud comme à
l'intérieur du Nord tu vois si tu prends
en Europe les 50 % les plus pauvres
actuellement sont à 4 5 tonnes
d'émissions équivalent en carbone par an
alors il faut que ça baisse faut que ça
arrive vers 2 3 mais ils sont pas
complètement à côté de la plaque les les
les plus riches sont à 50 tonnes les 1 %
les plus riches sont à 120 tonnes donc
si tu dis à tout le monde bah écoutez on
va tout réduire proportionnellement avec
une énorme taxe carbone une énorme
augmentation des prix de l'énergie les
mecs qui sont à 5 tonnes à 4 tonnes tu
vois s'ils ont pas tous les chiffres ils
savent tout ça don donc ils vont dire
bah attends pour on veut bien faire des
efforts mais les types qui sont à 50
tonnes ou à 100 tonnes tu vas commencer
par les ratibiser sérieusement et
ensuite bon bah nous aussi on va on
pourra peut-être aussi nous baisser mais
tu peux pas tu vois ça peut pas être
proportionn
pour tout le monde donc la question des
des inégalités et la question de
l'énergie sont sont intimement relié il
y a pas de solution à notre problème
énergétique avec le niveau d'inégalité
qu'on a actuellement et alors c'est
quand même relié à nos histoires sur le
vote parce que cette grande coupure
entre le vote des petites villes vote
rural et le vote des métropoles ça se
fait en particulier sur une
incompréhension sur cette question
énergétique c'estd que quand les
personnes qui ont un pavillon dans une
petite ville qui prennent leur voiture
individuelle pour aller au travail on
cherche y compris lorsqu'ils sont pas
très riches on cherche à les
culpabiliser ce qu'ils entendent parfois
du discours des urbains en disant c'est
de votre faute vous les ruraux avec
votre pavillon votre voiture c'est vous
qui faites le réchauffement climatique
en oubliant au passage que parfois les
urbains qui tiennent ce discours vont
prendre l'avion pour aller à Barcelone
en weekend et qu' taxe à zéro le kéosè
des avions là il y a un gros problème
c'est-à-dire que c'est on en revient au
truc c'est qu'il va falloir inventer un
système où on différencie les gens
suivant si si tu es à 1000 € de revenu à
10000 € de revenus et et et suivant
citit bah à 4 tonnes d'émission carbone
ou à 40 tonnes parce qu'en pratique les
deux sont quand même très très relié he
faut pas se raconter d'histoire
d'ailleurs je sais que tu veux pas
parler du bouquin mais il y a un
résultat qui est très intéressant de ce
point de vue là dans le livre à un
moment
donné on a un chapitre qui dit en gros
le le vote écolo peut-il être un vote
populaire parce qu'en fait si tu
regardes la structure du vote tout à
l'heure on disait le vote Macron est-il
le plus bourgeois de l'histoire et je
rappelais l'importance de de de montrer
que le vote de gauche en général est
rester un vote très fortement populaire
c'est vrai pour le parti communiste
c'est vrai pour le Parti socialiste y
compris aujourd'hui c'est très fortement
vrai pour la France insoumise un petit
bout ouais mais c'est combien 1,7% la
dernière présidentielle c'est 1,7 % mais
municipal ils font mieux aux européenes
ils vont faire un mieux y Jér qui revent
on on est on est sauvé tu pouras
l'inviter pour parler d'évasion fiscal
sera un très bon c'est pas bête en fait
ce rés là parce que regarde rappelle-toi
Kenedy après après je voulais dire un
truc sur les vers mais on va faire la
parenthèse Kennedy non non si je ouais
non mais du coup tu as une exception à
ça cette relation entre le le le fait
que les classes populaires votent
davantage à gauche c'est le vote écolo
nous on remonte à la première
candidature écolo 1974 René Dumont et
après tu as des candidats écolo de
manière systématique entre 74 et bris
Lalonde et aujourd'hui à l'exception de
de de 2017 et ce qui est vraiment
frappant c'est que depuis 74 pour le
coup tu as une relation croissante entre
le revenu et le vote écolo à l'exception
des 1 % 5 5 % 1 % des communes les plus
riches donc là on peut se dire que
vraiment dans les très très beaux
quartiers ils votent pas écolo parce
qu'ils associent ça un peu trop à la
gauche et que la gauche leur fait peur
mais sinon sur toute la distribution de
revenus tu as un vote qui est de plus en
plus élevé pour les écolos avec
l'augmentation du revenu et ça c'est
vraiment une contradiction complète au
sein du bloc de gauche parce que tous
les autres électorats de gauche sont des
électorats populaires il faut essayer de
comprendre pourquoi tu vois il faut
essayer de comprendre pourquoi et c'est
pas un truc truc de com c'est pas juste
Yannick jado a pas été bon pour parler à
l'ensemble des citoyens français c'était
un truc de com ça serait pas
systématique depuis 74 74 81 88 95 2002
le seul pour lequel c'est un tout petit
peu moins vrai encore c'est 2002 ma mère
mais il se trouve qu'en face de lui il a
une Noël ma mère oui pas ma mère qui qui
aurait très fortement voté écolo si elle
pouvait mais il a en face d'elle une
candidate écolo de droite à l'époque
donc il vient lui prendre un petit peu
du vote bourgeois écolo et puis on le
retrouve très fortement avec jado en
fait c'est tout à fait vrai pour jado
c'est le deuxième vote le plus marqué
avec le revenu depuis celui pour pour
René Dumont donc c'est intéressant de
comprendre pourquoi et on pense que
fondamentalement c'est dû au fait
qu'aujourd'hui he les écolos ont quand
même un discours qui est trop
culpabilisant manière de montrer du
doigt l'artificialisation des sols la
petite propriété pavillonnaire la
voiture individuelle et cetera et pour
juger le disc comme ça ah ben une
citoyenne donc du coup je me rends aux
hurnes et je décide est-ce que je ve V
colo est-ce que je vote les fill est-ce
que je vote PS est-ce que je vote Macron
voilà et puis deuxièmement le truc qui
est qui est frappant c'est qu'ils
arrivent pas en tout cas aujourd'hui
dans leur discours il ne lit pas la
question du changement climatique il ne
lit pas la question de la lutte contre
le changement climatique à la question
de la redistribution de la justice
sociale et qu'il faut juste rappeler
quelque chose qu'il y a des bonnes
raisons pour laquelle on a inventé par
exemple l'impôt progressif sur le revenu
on taxe pas pareil le 1emier euro de
revenu le 100è€os de revenu le milliè€
revenu le 1 million euros de revenus et
qu'il faut faire exactement pareil pour
la taxation du carbone il y a aucune
raison de taxer de la même manière la
première tonne de carbone la 10è tonne
la cè tonne la millième tonne et que
tant que les écolos auront pas lié ces
deux questions là et de dire qu'on va
faire de la redistribution sur la lutte
contre le changement climatique comme on
le fait sur le revenu bah il passe à
côté finalement de de de de de de de la
seule façon de parler aux classes
populaires qui sentent bien en fait
l'injustice actuelle dans dans les
politiques de de taxation de taxation
bonne alors avant de reparler du bouquin
qu'on veut pas parler euh vous sentez
comment l'évolution des choses en Europe
en France quand on voit l'Argentine
passer à un vote anarcholibéral
anarcolibéral je sais pas comment on dit
comme tronçonneuse vote à la
tronçonneuse c'est
ça vous vous voyez en considérant les
fondamentaux de soutenabilité de notre
économie les fondamentaux des banques
centrales les fondamentaux
inflationnistes les fondamentaux de
consommation
matière première d'énergie le vote vous
le sentez comment évoluer je veux dire
on peut en parler on peut parler des
résultats au paysb et cetera l'Argentine
aujourd'hui par rapport à la France
c'est quand même deux situations
politiques qui sont difficilement
comparables les é qu'on va avoir une
situation à l'Argentine avir 140 %
d'inflation en France non bah non parce
qu'on a en fait on a quand même une
vraie différence c'est qu'on a une
monnaie forte l'Argentine va pas refaire
toute
l'histoire non mais par rapport par
rapport au P non mais c'està dire il
faut il faut prendre ce qui s passé
toute l'histoire argentine depuis les
années 90 on peut le faire je veux dire
le leur tentative d'abord une première
fois de se rattacher au dollar c'est pas
loin bon c'est une politique où en fait
ils ont sub pendant des années oui puis
après les les fond votours le fait que
ils peuvent pas défendre leur monnaie en
gros c'est une monnaie qui est trop
petite pour que la banque centrale la
défendre et c'est ça qui fait que M il
peut arriver et dire bah moi je vais
détruire la banque centrale pourquoi il
peut dire ça c'est pas que les électeurs
argentins sont des abrutis les électeurs
argentins sont pas desabrutis mais à un
moment donné on leur donne deux
candidats tu m et en face tuas Macri ma
c'est qui c'est le ministre des Finances
sortant je veux dire il faut quand même
avoir un sens politique un tout petit
peu réduit pour aller présenter aux
élections présidentielles comme candidat
le ministre des Finances sortant avec
140 % d'inflation donc tu as une
certaine rationalité finalement dans le
choix des électeurs qui se disent bon ça
marche pas avec la banque centrale
actuel ça ne marche pas ça marche pas
avec le ministre des Finances actuel
donc on va voter pour quelque chose
d'autre mais on peut pas comparer avec
la France on pourrait comparer dans une
situation avec l'Italie si jamais on
avait pas l'euro ou avec la Grèce si la
Grèce était sortie de l'euro on a au
moins et je on défend pas entièrement la
politique de l'Union européenne il y a
des problèmes avec la politique
monétaire on peut faire mieux on peut
comparer avec ce que fait la Fed mais tu
as quand même un avantage d'avoir une
monnaie forte c'est que tu peux avoir
des politiques qui te permettent de
lutter contre les attaques des marchés
financiers et tu peux avoir des
politiques qui te permettent quand même
de mieux réguler sur la question de de
l'inflation un avantage qui se fait sur
le dos du reste du monde quand même
juste pour bien dire que vas-y on a une
monnaie forte pourquoi parce que les la
zone euro et les États-Unis sont les les
pays capitalistes les plus puissants de
la planète et tu sais on a souvent parlé
du privilège exorbitant du dollar en
fait aujourd'hui on a le privilège
exorbitant du dollar et de l'euro
c'est-à-dire que on est toujours
assezmerveillé Yan non beaucoup moins le
échang sur Swift c'est combien là
beaucoup moins non mais ce qui compte
c'est que tu vois combien un pays quand
il s'end dette à combien il emprunte et
les les pays de la la zone euro les
États-Unis là on est tout le temps à
s'émerveiller on emprunte à 0 % alors là
ça un peu augmenté 1 2 % mais ça reste
en dessous de l'inflation sauf que dans
les pays du Sud de l'autre côté tu as
des taux d'intérêt qui eux sont sont
montés à 5 10 20 % parfois en taux
d'intérêt réel et qui vont te bouffer au
Kenya la moitié du budget va être bouffé
par les intérêts de la dette au lieu de
payer des écoles et des hôpitaux donc tu
vois au lieu de s'émerveiller sur le
fait les intérêt de la dette en France
bah ça ceci ça fait ça doit faire 2 % du
PIB actuellement 30 40 milliards d'euros
ce qui est déjà trop hein dans la dans
l'absolu le niveau d'endettement public
qu'on a actuellement on a déjà vu ça
dans l'histoire au moment de la
Révolution française
ça c'est terminé avec la révolution on a
vu ça après la première et la seconde
guerre mondiale d'ailleurs on s'en est
débarrassé souvent avec des prélèvements
exceptionnels sur les plus haut
patrimoine privé parce qu'à un moment il
y a pas 36000 façons tu vois de on n'est
pas endetté vis-à-vis de la planète Mars
on est endetté vis-à-vis de nous-même
c'est des groupes sociaux qui détiennent
les titres de la dette soit tu fais
payer au plus pauvres avec l'inflation
c'est l'impôt sur les petits
patrimoinees soit tu fais payer au plus
riches avec des impôts exceptionnels sur
le patrimine privé il y a un moment tu
peux tu peux dire qu'il y a d'autres
solutions mais il faut tu fais des faut
mais tu fais aussi payer au plus riche
dans ce cas parce que c'est eux qui
détienent la dette oui ou enfin si tu
fais dé faut de façon de façon
désorganisée tu peux aussi avoir des
faillites bancaires qui retombent un peu
sur tout le monde donc c'est pas
forcément super donc il faut à un moment
il faut organiser la répartition sociale
de de de l'effort finalement parce qu'
un moment donné on est voilà on est
endetté vis-à-vis de-à-is de nousmême
souscrire une dette à tau variable c'est
intéressant ou pas bah non si c'est pour
se retrouver avec des des des marchés te
font te font monter à des niveau é pas
bien non non c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas une bonne idée ça peut être orig
mais mais parce que des pays après
peuvent se retrouver notamment des des
pays pauvres des pays qui sont plus
faible dans le dans les rapport de
pouvoir du capitalisme international
l'Argentine par exemple tu parles de la
France là non non mais attend là là tu
vois pas c'est les pays riches non mais
là tu nous parles la France c'est un
pays hyper riche c'est pas non mais la
France l'Allemagne les États-Unis c'est
le cœur du capitalisme Monal gens qui
dorment dans la rue avec 3000 enfants
qui dment
par mais le pays n'a jamais été aussi
riche le pays n'a jamais été aussi riche
et simplement on répartit mal c'estàd
qu'on pourrait choisir de répartir
autrement mais c'est vrai que quand
j'entends dire aujourd'hui voilà on peut
pas résoudre le problème du malogement
et on peut rien faire pour les pays du
Sud on est vraiment trop pauvre on est
obligé de faire mourir les gens dans la
Méditerranée on dit on traite tellement
bien nos migrants qu'on en attire encore
plus alors que les gens dorment je il
faut regarder quand même autour des
gares à Paris dans les grandes villes il
faut regarder ce qui se passe à calé il
faut regarder les migrants ils meurent
enfin ils meurent en dormant dans la rue
et pas que des migrants mais quand même
beaucoup c'est vrai que dans le même
temps tu as la discussion d'une loi sur
l'immigration qui disent qu'il faut
absolument rendre tout plus restrictif
et avoir plus de renvois dans les pays
d'origine parce qu'on a aujourd'hui une
politique trop attractive moi j'aimerais
bien savoir qu'est-ce qui est attractif
aujourd'hui dans le fait d'avoir les
gens à la rue qui ont pas de quoi
nourrir qui ont pas pas de de de quoi se
loger et à qui on n même pas capable
d'offrir un toit tous les soirs y
compris ENF d'ailleurs c'est c'est un
problème pour les hommes mais y compris
pour des des femmes avec des enfants qui
peuvent accoucher dans la rue
aujourd'hui quoi et on est en France et
on a les moyens de le faire c'est pas
parce qu'on est un pays pauvre en
Argentine c'est différent là en
Argentine tu as un vrai problème c'estd
tu as des gens qui peuvent plus
s'acheter à manger parce que tu as trop
d'inflation en France on n pas ce
problème là c'est c'est un choix de de
de mauvaise répartition de ressources
les Français sautent beaucoup de repas
en ce moment non ah ben parce que tu as
un problème de pouvoir d'achat bah si on
prend pour le coup population ou du
reste à vivre bah il y a plus beaucoup
de reste à vivre enfin tu le définis
comme tu veux mais mais si tu regardes
définissent pour moi non mais
aujourd'hui sur la question de la PR ité
étudiante par exemple c'est un véritable
problème c'estàd que tu vois il y a
plein de politiques qu'on pourrait
mettre en œuvre il y a des politiques
d'avoir des bourses étudiante par
exemple qu'on pourrait donner
automatiquement à 18 ans pour mettre
déjà pour commencer les étudiants sur
une situation d'égalité c'està-dire pas
des étudiants qui peuvent bénéficier des
revenus de leurs parents versus d'autres
qui doivent travailler tu as la queue
aux distributions alimentaires qui
arrête pas d'augmenté et c'est documenté
par le cru et cetera et cetera tous ces
problèmes là ils existent c'est pas un
problème de manque de ressources c'est
pas parce que la France est un pays
pauvre la France est un pays riche c'est
un problème de répartition de revenus et
c'est un problème de politique qui sont
mené la France est un ah ben pour très
longtemps mais ça faut arrêter de
s'ppitoyer sur notre sort de dire voilà
on décroche c'est la fin il y a des
politiques qu'on pourrait mieux mener il
y a des trucs sur lesquels on décroche
sur la question de la
désindustrialisation tant et pour le
coup il y a une responsabilité de
l'Union européenne tant qu'on aura pas
des vraies politiques en particulier de
de de de protectionnisme mais pas en
terme de protectionnisme pur c'estàdire
de de de justice finalement aux
frontières notamment sur les questions
fiscales notamment sur les questions
sociales notamment sur les questions
environnementales là sur les questions
de de de concurrence internationale on
va décrocher mais vraiment se lamenter
en disant voilà c'est plus comme avant
on était 3e puissance mondiale pu que 5e
on est passé au 6e rang au 7è an c'est
vraiment une blague c'est pas de ça dont
on devrait discuter ce dont on devrait
discuter c'est la répartition des
ressources à l'intérieur de ce pays et
puis aussi surtout ça ça nous inviterait
quand même beaucoup de nous plaindre sur
l'avenir c'est combien on investit dans
notre jeunesse ça on en revient à ce que
disait Thomas tout à l'heure sur sur
l'université c'est si on augmente pas
les dépenses de formation si on nugmente
pas l'investissement dans la jeunesse
demain en France bah oui on va avoir une
France qui risque de décrocher parce que
tout pour le coup tous les gains de
productivité qu'on a eu sur le long
terme ça s'est fait avec l'éducation et
sur la question du virage régagnant en
1980 ce que Thomas rappelait tout à
l'heure quand on a eu la politique de
réduction des inégalités aux États-Unis
à partir de Roosevelt tout au long des
années 40 50 60 70 tu vas avoir des taux
marginales d'imposition sur le revenus
aux États-Unis qui vont être de l'ordre
de 80 90 % tout en haut et l'économie se
porte bien c'est lestrente glorieus à
partir de Rean tu fais baisser
l'imposition tu fais réexploser les
inégalités et le taux de croissance de
l'économie ralenti c'est intéressant de
comprendre pourquoi et une partie des
raisons pour lesquelles on observe ça
c'est à cause du du décrochage scolaire
et du décrochage de la formation et du
décrochage universitaire alors pas parce
que tu vois les gens vont toujours être
focalisés tu as encore Harvard mit
Stanford mais c'est pas ça comme ça que
tu tu tu formes la réalité d'un pays tu
vois tu peux dire en France bah a encore
hen 4 Normal Sup et technique c'est pas
ça qui te dit comment tu formes
l'ensemble d'une population et on a
arrêté de mettre de l'argent pour
éduquer l'ensemble des citoyens pris en
masse pas juste une une élite de 1 % et
on est en train de faire la même chose
en France nous hier je donne un exemple
he on était on était à Saint-Denis on
était à Paris 8 tu arrives à
l'université saint-elis en fait il il
venaient de sortir paniqué du fait qu'on
a failli annuler la conférence qu'ils
avaient pas d'électricité dans le
bâtiment pendant la moitié de la journée
tu imagines les conditions
d'enseignement pas ils avent pas parce
qu'il y a pas d'argent qui est mis du
coup ils font des travaux en en plein
pendant les cours les budgets ça permet
pas à l'université de tomber dessus les
amphis s'effondrent même pour les
étudiants c'est dégradant en fait
d'aller étudier là-bas en fait ils ont
envie d'étudier il se disent mais c'est
quoi ces conditions d'enseignement pour
les profs c'est difficile et c'est comme
ça qu'on prépare notre jeunesse donc à
un moment donné arrêtons de dire qu'on
va vers le décrochage en fait on a les
moyens pour que ça aille mieux mais ça
suppose aussi de faire les bons
investissement le budget le budget par
étudiant en France au cours des 10
dernières années a baissé a baissé de 20
% et le pire c'est qu'on aille face à un
gouvernement et ça c'était déjà le cas
en fait sous Hollande inflation comprise
après avoir défalqué l'inlation c'est ça
le problème c'est que le le les
gouvernements successifs pensent qu'ils
ont qu'ils ont qu'ils sont face à des
analphabètes qui qui à qui ils peuvent
dire bah regardez ça a augmenté il y a
l'inflation mais bon on défale que
l'inflation c'est à peu près ça stagne
sauf que le nombre d'étudiants lui-même
augmenté de 20 % donc si on divise par
le nombre d'étudiants après avoir retiré
l'inflation là on baisse de 20 % par
étudiant et ce qui est quand même
complètement paradoxal c'est qu'on vit
dans un monde où on dit voilà l'économie
de la connaissance innovation et C
préparer l'avenir la startup nation et
cetera et vous faites ça et vous faites
ça avec un investissement par étudiant
qui chutent de 20 % avec des
conséquences très concrètes c'est des
bâtiments que vous que vous arrêtez de
chauffer et vous renvoyez les gens à
faire des cours en zoom parce que vous
pouvez plus ouvrir et payer
l'électricité dans le bâtiment donc ça
c'est des trucs c'est un gâi c'est un
gâi incroyable bah quand j'entends ça je
je suis non je suis je suis très je suis
très énervé je pense que la solution
elle est à nouveau dans la la
mobilisation politique dans le dans le
dans la confrontation démocratique et
moi je suis très énervé quand aussi on
se mobilise pas assez donc moi j'ai
aussi envie de dire aux gens qui ne
votent pas voilà il y a un moment il
faut aller voter comment tu veux miliser
quand tu te prends des coups de LBD 40
en pleine tête comme dans un pays du
tiermonde pas quand tu vas voter mais ça
tu un problème des manif en France ça
c'est vrai mais ça ça a été des
techniques contre insurrectionnel d' ça
empêche pas ça empêche pas non plus
d'aller voter ça empêche pas de
participer à des à des mouvements
politiques de participer à des syndicats
parce que c'est voilà c'est important
toutes ces organisations que parfois on
associe au passé mais qui vont qui
doivent se réorganiser qui doivent se se
structurer autrement mais qui reste
absolument indispensable et qui sont bah
la question c'est qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de faire quand
tu vois ça mais non mais ce que j'ai
envie de faire d'abord c'est de
la pas la greffe de la fin moi moi tu
sais moi je crois aussi tu vois
l'évolution du vote en France moi je
pense que d'abord un des résultats
optimistes
de notre bouquin parce que je pense
c'est important vachement beau tous les
deux hein ouais merci c'est gentil c'est
faut pas nous flatter ensuite pour poser
une question si tu veux un des résultats
optimistes de notre bouquin c'est que
les les comportements de vote en France
aujourd'hui sont beaucoup plus
déterminés par des questions concrètes
de profession d'accès à l'emploi d'accès
au logement de revenus de richesse des
questions socio-économiques concrètes
sur lesquell il y a des débouché que sur
des questions d'identité ou d'origine
c'est nous concrètement quand one e les
écarts de vote en 2022 au derniè
présidentielle on arrive à expliquer
jusqu'à 70 % des écarts de vote entre
commune en prenant en compte la richesse
de la commune la taille d'agglomération
et de commune la les professions les
propions d'ouvriers d'employés de
diplôme si on rajoute les origines donc
le pourcentage de personnes de
différentes nationalités étrangères
d'immigrés et cetera on explique à 2 à 3
% des écarts de vote entre communes
autrement dit ce qui détermine d'abord
le vote des uns et des autres ce sont
voilà l'insertion dans le tissu
territorial et productif la profession
les problèmes d'accès au logement les
problèmes d'accès à
l'emploi alors l' sécurité la sécurité
ça peut ça peut compter aussi mais pas
forcément dans le sens qu'on croit pas
forcément dans le sens qu'on croit c'est
ce qu'on voit c'est que les les communes
où il y a le plus la plus grande
insécurité en fait vont plutôt voter un
peu plus pour la gauche parce qu'ils se
font pas d'illusion sur le fait que
Sarkozi c'est lui qui a supprimé le le
plus grand nombre d'emplo de policiers
parce qu'à un moment pour payer des
policiers ou la justice il faut aussi il
faut aussi des impôts pour payer des
services publics et par contre les
origines dans tout ça parce que quel que
soi vos origines l'insécurité c'est
aussi un problème c'est pasorigine
l'insécurité c'est pas juste un problème
pour les blancs contre ceux qui sont pas
blancs et cetera donc toutes ces
questions d'origine sur lequel se
focalise trop souvent le débat public en
fait c'est pas ça qui fait que les gens
se déplacent d'ailleurs si les gens
étaient fascinés par les conflits liés
aux origines aux identités avec toute
l'offre politique qu'il y a de du
rassemblement nationale de reconquête et
cetera on aura une participation de 90
%. hein si la participation a tombé a
tombé à moins de 50 30 % ça montre bien
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui se retrouent
pas dans dans tout ce dans tout ce
délire identitaire et donc ce on a
besoin aujourd'hui et c'est ça le
résultat positif quand même qu'il y a
dans le dans le bouquin à la fin c'est
que on a besoin de parties qui si tu
veux parle plus des question d'accès au
logement à la propriété y compris les
questions d'habitat pavillonnaire de de
de de transport d'énergie qui sont bah
tu me donnes notre couquin vas-y je te
le prends oui absolument il y a des des
des résultats très positifs dans ce
bouquin qui je crois permettent
permettent de de de montrer qu'on n'est
pas dans cette espèce
d'archipélisation de communautarisme
généralisé de conflit identitaire que
certains nous racontent aujourd'hui on
est c'est vrai dans une situation où il
y a des des divisions entre électorats
euh des petites villes d'électorats des
grandes métropoles mais qui pour nous
sont plus liés à des insertions
différentes dans le tissu productif
c'est si vous êtes un un ouvrier pour un
revenu donné si vous êtes un ouvrier
dans une petite ville vous avez été vous
avez subi la concurrence commerciale
européenne vous avez l'impression
d'avoir été oublié par la droite et la
gauche qui se sont succédés au pouvoir
si vous êtes un bas salaire dans dans
dans les métiers du soin dans les
métiers du nettoyage dans les banlieux
vous continuez davantage de voter à
gauche peut-être parce que vous avez été
moins soumis aussi à cette concurrence
internationale qui a détruit les emplois
donc il y a eu des expériences
individuelles différentes mais à
laquelle on peut apporter des réponses
sur la R industrialisation sur la taxe
carbone au frontiè je prend là tu fais
un peu panneau
publicitairewich j'aimerais que tu me
l'ouvres un peu parce qu'il y a plein de
cartes
oui contraement ou c'est contrairement
contrairement à tout un tas de bouquins
alors c'est en couleur d'abord par qui
est assez joli mais a je sais pas si non
mais si c'est vrai en général les livres
c'est en noir et blanc c'est pas beau là
le il est un peu lourd parce que le
papier est épais on va faire la pu
jusqu' et du coup il y a des il y a des
jolies cartes voilà je sais pas si on
peut zoomer sur les cartes non ce qui
est important aussi-moi des plus jolies
cartes s'il te plaît bon vas-y
cherche non mais je qui cherche vas-y
pour le coup ce qui est important aussi
c'est que tu as quand même tout ça sur
le site où tu peux télécharger les
cartes sur une histoire
duclitpolitique.fg en France ouais
c'estberger en France ouais mais non je
voulais dire un truc est joli mais bon
en tout cas il
y c'est gavé de cartte c'est gavé de
sources donc il y a moyen de challenger
tout ça surtout de voir où où est-ce que
vous allez chercher vos données juste on
reviendra sur les données comment vous
avez été les chercher si ça vous a coûé
pogon pas du pognon et et la dangerosité
de mettre ça dans un livre de mettre
quoi dans un livre des datas comme ça là
pourquoi c'est dangereux c'est bien oui
non mais c'est bien mais ça peut être
dangereux pourquoi c'est dangereux B
imagine-toi qu'on a un effondrement de
l'euro et que les gens commencent à se
Fighter là il y a marqué là où il faut
aller pour aller chercher les sous là
non ah non ah tu tu tu tu veux dire dans
quelle commune mais ça les gens le
savent très bien prend mais là c'est
vachement bien expliqué quand même non
mais je sais pas tu prends par exemple
c'est assez intéressant tiens tu as une
carte je sais pas si c'est cellel qu'on
a vu où on va mettre le le revenu moyen
en France en 2022 combien reven
moyenance c'est 19200 € par par an par
habitant ce qui est intéressant non
avant impôt ce qui est habitant c'est ce
qui est ah intéressant c'est de regarder
la répartition tu prends des communes
parmi les 10 % des communes les plus
pauvres je sais pas tu prends roubé par
exemple dans le Nord on est à 8900 € par
an hein ça fait autour de 800 € par mois
tu prendsér de VI roué c'est combien
alors ça je sais pas par contre on n pas
le niveau d'espérence de de
que dans Paris 7 ouais et tu prends
Paris 7 par exemple on est auudessus on
est à 107000 à peu près euros par an par
habitant ce qui fait qu'en fait on est à
10000 € par mois enfant compris c'est fa
qu'en
gros donc en gros un foyer deux parents
deux enfants c'est 40000 € donc après tu
peux dire qu'il y a y a peut-être ai ça
c'est juste le revenu qui est dans la
déclaration de revenu avant toute
déduction àattement y compris avant
déduction de 10 % propessionnel mais ça
n'inclut pas tous les
revenusation non mais non mais ça inclut
pas si tu as les revenus qui
s'accumulent dans une boîte et ca c'est
même pas pris en compte donc là c'est
vraiment le revenu de la déclaration de
revenu minimale et ça monte à 10000 €
par mois donc y compris les enfants à
Paris 7e c'est à 700 800 € par mois à
roubet ou ou à pentin ou à s de l'autre
côté pour dire c'est parce qu'on l' mis
dans une carte que les
gens les gens se sont déjà aperçus c'est
il y a pas besoin de notre livre pour le
coup pour le savoir là où tu as besoin
de notre livre c'est pour voir comment
ça évolué dans le temps 1 et puis de de
voir comment ça explique aujourd'hui les
comportements V sa au début du 20e
siècle céit encore plus élevé que ça
ceci dit les écarts les écarts entre
communes ou au 19e siècle tu vois
aujourd'hui sur le le prix d'un logement
aujourd'hui le logement moyen en France
c'est 220000 €. vierson 65000 € le prix
moyen 7e arrondissement 1,2 million
d'euros donc ça tu as un écart de de 1 à
20 sur le prix moyen des logements au
19e siècle tu pouvais être à 1 à 40 1 à
50 donc surface comparable à surface
comparable parce que c'est lu prix mètre
carré là essentiellement qui qui bouge
et donc c'est pour dire que voilà les
inégalités aujourd'hui sont gigantesques
elles étaient encore plus fortes il y a
un siècle elles se sont réduites aussi
dans le long terme c'est aussi ça le
message positif grâce à des
mobilisations politiques sociales c'est
c'est pas un truc qui s'est fait comme
ça comme par enchantement les guerres
les bombardements bon ça a aussi joué
mais c'est pas ça l'essentiel
l'essentiel ça a été un truc constructif
et donc pour nous le le message n
positif optimiste sur lequel je veux
insister c'est que ce processus il peut
continuer et il va continuer c'est nous
à un moment la dem
sociale d'égalité de progrès elle reste
très forte donc il y a un moment il y a
la déprime on on se recroie sur des des
thèmes identitaires nous contre les
autres et cetera mais à la fin des fins
c'est pas ça qui va résoudre les
problèmes donc Trump on a essayer il est
reparti al il va peut-être revenir parce
que Biden n pas été terrible mais inér
prendre l'exemple de ce qui s'est passé
en Hongrie là tout le monde là se
focalise on
dit en Pologne je suis fatigué en mme
temps c'est ça à force de nous faire
parler pendant pendant des heures non
mais tu vois tout le
monde non non mais on est encore chaud
on est encore chaud euh mais tu tout le
monde se focalise là sur met en
Argentine ou ce qui s'est passé au
Pays-Bas bon ben la polne c'était un
mois avant personne n'en a parlé et elle
est arrivé enfin la la la gauche c'est
pas des des gauche gauchiste on va dire
que le
le l'extrême droite au pouvoir qui a été
tenté qui a étéit réélu bah finalement
elle était abandonné donc tu as quand
même des des retours de balancier quoi
c'est pas juste le monde entier est en
train de basculer à l'extrême droite et
ça serait une défaite généralisée de la
gauche par contre tu as de la
responsabilité des partis de gauche
aujourd'hui et ils ont un gros travail à
faire à commencer par la France pour
qu'on revienne une situation
d'alternance politique en 2027 ça c'est
évident alors comme vous voulez pas
répondre à ma question de comment vous
voyez le le le vote évolué en France je
vais vous poser une question mais tu es
pas clair si tu veux spécifier pardon
non c'est vrai non nous on pense puisque
tu me redemandes sur la France on est
dans une situation où le le bloc de
gauche est est est plus fort que ce
qu'on raconte et c'est pas qu'il soit
très très fort et que ce soit très
facile de revenir au pouvoir mais par
rapport au au aux deux autres bloc que
le le bloc de droite autour du
rassemblement national avec reconquête
LR il est en fait complètement
incohérent c'est bon pour être contre
les immigrés ils sont à peu près
d'accord mais pour le reste s'il faut
qu'il vote une loi sur les retraites un
budget des services publics des impôts
tu vois entre ce que veut le Pen ce que
veut Zemour c'est c'est complètement
incohérent et et et ça ferait
immédiatement beaucoup de déçus si
jamais ils arrivent au pouvoir je je dis
pas qu' il faut TER non c'est pas mon
interprétation c'est quand tu regardes
les programmes de de Zemour ou de soioti
qui veulent supprimer tous les impôts
tous les services publics les programmes
du RN qui dit on va remettre des
services public sur les retraites sur
les retraite d'un côté tuasas leupen qui
dit il faut arriver à 60 ans en fait
c'est toujours moi qui parle en général
donc c'est pas mal qu'il puisse
s'exprimer pour une fois alors que quand
tu prends Zemour ouotive elle a 67 ans
donc en fait le truc il marche pas du
tout et ce qui est vraiment frappant
face à ces incohérences là c'est si tu
regardes sur le bloc de gauche en fait
Thomas il rappela tout à l'heure donc il
parle un petit peu mais il rappelait
tout à l'heure quand il avait la parole
le le le le le fait que sur le
rassemblement national c'est pas un vote
qui se fait principalement sur des
raisons identitaires c'est un vote qui
se fait sur des raisons
socio-économiques sentiment d'abandon
désindustrialisation concurrence
internationale et ce qui est vraiment
frappant et un des trucs qu'on monte
dans le livre c'est pour le coup toi tu
as toute une littérature enfin des gens
qui vont prétendre qu'on a simplement un
espèce d'opposition centre périphérique
grande ville territoire unandonné et que
il y aurait pas du tout de
préoccupations communes en fait il y a
des préoccupations communes qui sont
gigantesques aujourd'hui tu prends la
France et on le documente avec des
chiffres dans le livre tu as plus de
points communs entre un village pauvre
et une banlieue pauvre contre un village
pauvre et un village riche c'est sur ces
questions socio-économiques là prends la
question de la santé tu prends les deux
principaux trois principaux déserts
médicaux en France d'un côté tu as l'INE
et la Creuse de l'autre côté tu as la
Scine saint ils ont les les mêmes
préoccupations tu prends l'éducation
alors ça se pose pas exactement de la
même manière en s il y a des écoles il y
a pas de prof face aux élèves en Creuse
bah tu as un accès plus difficile à
l'école parce que tu as des fermetures
de classe mais c'est la même
préoccupation et c'est ça en fait qui
fait que on pense qu'il y a la
possibilité pour les partis de gauche
d'aller reconquérir cet électorat
populaire rural en étant capable de lui
parler et en étant capable notamment de
lui parler sur des politiques de réforme
de l'Union européenne pour lutter contre
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui en terme de
désindustrialisation concurrence
internationale et puis en terme de de de
de de réinvestissement dans les services
publics quoi et ça c'est vraiment un des
points centraux qui se pose aujourd'hui
et ça ça nous rend optimiste tu as
grandi à nî j'ai pas grandi à nî j'ai
passé du temps à Marseille à Toulouse à
Bordeaux à Cambray à M
ouiin vous avez fait du terrain avec
votre bouquin ou c'est juste du travail
de r bibliothèque bah le terrain on le
fait comme comme tout le monde parce
qu'on a aussi des des origines
familiales très très diverses c'est toi
tes grand-mères à Cambray c'est
typiquement l'immigration espagnole qui
par rapport aux nouvelles vagues
migratoires aussi peut avoir des des
différences de perception moi j'ai
grandi en partie dans l'ude mes parents
sont dans l'indréloir depuis longtemps
bon on a on a comme comme nous tous on
est confronté à des des origines
différentes des situations différentes
et dans dans notre travail c'est vrai
qu'on on regarde d'abord ces cartes ces
données on essaie de faire des comp
raaison nous d'abord de poser des
comparaisons historiques qui avant
n'étaient pas possible parce que les
données avaient pas été rassemblées
après on tire des des conclusions on
vient de le dire qui sont des
conclusions peut-être un peu plus
optimistes que ce qu'on entend parfois
on pense que le vote est moins
identitaire que ce qu'on raconte plus
sociale économique que la possibilité de
revenir à des alternances gauche- droite
en France n'est pas forcément si éloigné
que ça au dernier scrutin en 2022 à 1 %
près Marine Le Pen était éliminé du
premier tour pense que le le
rassemblement nation nationale est est
moins fort que ce qu'on que ce qu'on
prétend et si elle avait été éliminée du
prier tour au second tour sans doute
Macron l'aurait emporté face à Mélenchon
mais on se serait rapproché d'un conflit
gauche- droite et Macron ça aurait pas
suffi d'aller dans les réserves de voie
côté pcres he pour gagner parce qu'il y
avait pas grandchose donc il aurait dû
aller chercher sur sur Zemour sur Le Pen
ce qui l'aurait obligé sur les questions
migratoires all sans doute assez loin
dans cette direction il l'aurait fait
sans doute sans aucune retenue mais ça
aurait remis le conflit politique plutôt
entre une une droite disons à la fois
libérale et un peu nationaliste sur les
bords et et et une gauche et ça aurait
préparé la suite on pense en tout cas
d'une façon plus intéressante que un
second tour Le Pen Macron ou voilà qui
qui ne semble pas très très intéressant
même si les les noms changent pour la
fois suivante c'est vraiment pas ce
qu'on peut espérer de mieux mais ce
qu'on voit sur les derniers scrutins à
nouveau c'est que ça s'est joué à peu de
choses près donc la situation actuelle
elle est elle est elle est très instable
elle est imprévisible nous on fait de
l'histoire on fait pas de la futurologie
mais on insiste quand même même sur le
le le le les potentialités de revenir
sur un conflit gauche- droite qui malgré
toutes les limites a quand même permis
les alternances démocratiques a permis
la construction de l'État social et a
été enfin finalement c'est le c'est le
pire système à l'exception de tous les
autres c'est-à-dire que de permettre à
deux camps qui ont chacun en partie
raison et chacun des choses à apporter
d'alterné au pouvoir et puis voilà bah
on passe au suivant si on n'est pas
content bah ça ça donne une force de
rappel qui qui est toujours imparfaite
et ça remplacera pas les mobilisations
sociales les manifestations et toutes
sortes d'autres mobilisations mais cette
force de rappel quand on l'a plus on se
rend compte de ce qu'on a perdu
d'ailleurs on donne des exemples
intéressants par rapport à ça dans le
dans le bouquin c'est pas quand quand on
dit de l'alternance gauche- droite on n'
pas eu le progrès social uniquement
quand la gauche était au pouvoir et le
recul social quand la droite était au
pouvoir tu prends le le le plus le taux
d'impôt sur le revenu le plus progressif
de l'histoire de France il est voté en
1920 par une chambre élue en 1919 qu'on
appelle la chambre bleu horizon parce
que c'est la chambre la plus à droite de
toute l'histoire de France et c'est la
chambre la plus à droite de toute
l'histoire de France qui va voter le
taux d'impôt progressif le plus
redistributif de l'histoire de France
pourquoi ils font ça mais parce que tu
as l'alternance parce que 1920 tu as eu
la révolution en 1917 parce qu'en fait
ils ont peur de perdre le pouvoir par
rapport aux socialistes ils savent que
c'est assez fragile que leur victoire
électorale est fragile ils préfèrent
aller dans le sens du progrès social
plutôt que de perdre les élections tu
regardes toutes les mesures de
progression du salaire minimum
augmentation de Bass salaire et cetera
en France 1967- 1968 c'est pas la gauche
qui est au pouvoir c'est la droite qui
est au pouvoir et la droite fait ça
pourquoi parce qu'elle a peur de perdre
les élections parce que il y a les
mouvements sociaux en 1968 donc là c'est
moitié mouvements sociaux mobilisation
moitié alternance et du coup en fait
elle va dans le sens du du progrès
social et c'est ça qui est vraiment
intéressant alors que Macron aujourd'hui
tu as plus de bipartition tu es dans une
situation de tripartition les classes
populaires sont divisés en deux tu as 75
% de la population contre lui sur les
retraitees il fait quand même les
retraite et c'est ça le problème du
système actuel c'est qu'on a plus
d'alternance et nous on est des partis
sont tellement divisés que moi de toute
façon je continue au milieu et je je
suis tranquille et c'est cette voilà
cette absence d'une force de rappel qui
qui qui est vraiment qui est vraiment
préjudiciable deux questions euh quel
quel était ou quelle a été votre lecture
des émeutes du mois de juin des pillages
où est-ce que ça a été fait quel type de
bien on été piqué quel type de snap avec
des steaks cchés des tranches de saumon
de la lessive mais faut faut faut
revenir d'où ça vient en fait parce que
par non c'est désolé je peux mais c'est
comme on te voit pas je me dis que c'est
non mais toi tu vois toi moi je te
vois la deuxième question c'est on est
on est aussi beaucoup écouté en Afrique
et on le passe le bonjour en Afrique
francophone quand nos amis qui nous
écoutent en Afrique subsaharienne vous
entend euh combler les inégalités le
progrès social à l'échelle planétaire on
fait comment pour combler les inégalités
je réponds sur les pièges je te laisse
répondre àess ok sur une division
domestique du travail euh sur la
question du c'est qui fait le ménage
c'est où fa la cuisine aussi mais moi je
suis je suis nulle en fait en tout ce
qui est ménage cuisine et tout ça mais
c'est pas c'est pas très intéressant
euh sur la question des pillage je pense
qu'il
faut il faut revenir au fondamentaux non
il faut voir quand même d'où ça vient en
je dire
fond je veux dire c'est pas des émeutes
urbaines qui viennent de nulle part
c'est des émeutes urbaines qui viennent
à partir d'un éniè épisode de violence
policière avec un éème tentative de
cacher ces violences policières
c'estàdire c'est pas simplement ce qui
s'est passé le fait que tu t
interprétation ouais c'est mon
interprétation mais encore une fois
c'est à la fois on peut dire que c'est
même une lecture citoyenne après tout
c'est pas grave je suis pas spécialiste
des des violenurbe mais tu me donnes la
parole donc je te dis la manière dont je
lis tu as à la fois la question de de la
violence du geste c'estd voilà tuas un
policier qui tire sur un jeune au volant
clairement pas dans une situation a
priori de de légitime défense et surtout
tu as le mensonge au départ alors
attendsel c'est bah c'està-dire qu'au
départ avant que tu es la vidéo les
policiers la manière dont il racontent
l'histoire c'est pas la manière dont ça
s'est passé et c'est vraiment je pense
que c'est la le le le lien entre les
deux je pense que si dès le départ tu
avait eu la vérité sur la manière dont
ça s'était passé ça aurait quand même
beaucoup moins énervé les gens et donc
se retrouve derrière le 4 c'est pas
normal c'est pas bien a priori le mec la
voiture qu'il avait peut-être qu'il
faisait du deal bon il méritait pas de
mourir pour autant je veux dire tu as
pas la peine de
mort é par les motards et c'est pas une
raison pour le tuer alors sinon il faut
il faut il faut la peine de mort donc tu
peux montrer du doigt pointer du doigt
autant que tu veux ce jeune homme est-ce
qu'il était parfait il était pas parfait
que DLE ilit il méritait pas de mourir
point voilà on va partir de ce point de
vue-là enfin je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord que les gens qui nous regardent
sont d'accord il méritaent pas de mourir
il meurt un de tu as une tentative de de
de de mensonge policière ça pose des
problèmes et ça déclenche des émeutes
ces émeutes elles nous disent plusieurs
choses un elles disent le problème bah
de la relation dans les banlieux et
cetera entre la police et les jeunes qui
est plus une relation aujourd'hui de
confiance ce qui pose énormément de
problèmes et on en revient d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure à ce que tu disais sur
Sarkozi la suppression de la police
d'effectif la suppression de la police
de proximité et cetera on voit la police
uniquement comme des forces répressives
alors qu'il y a quand même des approches
qui peuvent être des approches
différentes et deux c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans les histoire de pillage
et là ça a été extrêmement bien
documenté par les journalistes qui ont
pris le temps d'assister notamment au
compar tion immédiate c'est qu'on peut
toujours prendre l'exemple des jeunes
qui vont aller fracasser un magasin Nike
pour piquer des des baskets en disant
voilà c'est très très mal mais n'empêche
que derrière ça aussi parmi les gens qui
sont arrêtés tu as des gens qui vont se
chercher à bouffer dans un supermarché
et ça ça dit le problème des inégalités
aujourd'hui ça dit le problème de la
crise sur le pouvoir d'achat et c'est
vrai qu'ensuite que tu vois ces gens-là
se retrouver alors qu'ils ont jamais
commis le moindre délit jamais été
arrêté et ils sont pas allés piquer un
stylo Mont Blanc à 2000 € quoi ils sont
allés prendre une pizza dans dans un
supermarché parce que tout d'un coup bah
ils avaient cette opportunité et encore
c'est un grand mot là ils l'ont fait bah
ça dit surtout quelque chose sur la
crise de pouvoir d'achat le malaide dans
la société et le fait que les tensions
elles peuvent monter extrêmement vite et
s'il y avait moins je suis désolé d'
revenir là mais s'il y avait moins
d'inégalité économique et si il y avait
une perception de davantage de justice
sociale je pense pas qu'un événement
comme celui qui s'est produit en juin
aurait déclencher des scènes de de
violence et de pillage de de cette
ampleur donc les ingalité à l'échelle du
monde
Thomas on continue de d'échanger entre
européens ou tu as un plan pour combler
les inégalités à l'échelle mondiale bah
c'est-à-dire que si les pays riches
aujourd'hui refusent continuent de
refuser pour résumer de partager les
richesse de partager le pouvoir à un
moment donné ils vont se retrouver dans
une situation où c'est la la la Chine la
Russie le Brésil l'Inde enfin les
briques qui sont actuellement en train
de s'étendre avec 15 nouveaux pays qui
vont organiser euh le monde euh sans eux
c'est-à-dire que les pays européens et
nord-américains qui continuent de se
demander tiens pourquoi on n' pas le
soutien de toute la planète sur
l'Ukraine et la Russie euh alors que sur
les vaccins pendant le covid ils ont
tout gardé les doses pour eux
tranquillement euh sur les promesses de
réparation face aux dégâts climatiques
les sommes promises en 2015 qui étaient
de toute façon 10 fois plus faible que
ce qu'ell auraient dû être n'ont
toujours pas été versé c'est si on
change pas ce système-là ce qui veut
dire quoi ce qui veut dire concrètement
bah il y a les il y a tout le système de
gouvernance internationale de droit de
vote au FMI à la Banque mondiale pour
éviter que le système financier soit
d'abord fait pour que les pays riches
payent des taux d'intérêt quasi nul et
les pays pauvres sans des à non plus
finir avec des taux d'intérêt
invraisemblables il y a tout le système
fiscal international c'estàdire que le
tu sais il y a eu une réforme soi-disant
des de l'imposition minimale des
multinationales qui normalement
maintenant sont censés payer un minimum
de 15 % d'impôt ce qui déjà est pas
beaucoup parce que le garagiste du coin
la petite entreprise du coin elle va
payer 20 25 30 % et elle peut pas créer
une filiale en Irlande donc déjà le le
chiffre de 15 % est ridicule il y a
plein d'échappatoir
elle peut elle peut elle peut pas faire
la même chose mais le problème encore
plus grave que ça c'est que le le petit
surpl de recettes arrivant des des
paradis fiscaux a été partagé en fait
entre les pays riches c'estd c'est les
les administrations fiscales de des
États-Unis d'Allemagne de France et
cetera qui se partagent quelques
recettes supplémentaires dans des
paradis fiscaux les pays du Sud rien du
tout donc là la seule solution à la fois
face aux réparations climatiques parce
que ce sont les pays du Sud qui sont
actuellement une productivité agricole
en chute libre à cause du réchauffement
le Sahel ça a jamais été très facile de
faire pousser quelque chose mais là
c'est de pire en pire c'est qu'on a des
populations qui augmentent un déclin une
chute de la production agricole qui est
directement lié aux émissions faites par
les pays du Sud donc on est vraiment sur
de de fait on vole par les pays du donc
on est sur du vol caractérisé de de de
ressources pour lequel on promet des des
des des compensations pour essayer de
s'adapter à la à la situation parce que
malheureusement une partie des dégâts on
pourra pas revenir dessus sauf que les
promesses à chaque fois sont trahes donc
moi je pense que la la seule solution en
l'occurrence c'est de décider que au
moins une partie des recettes provenant
des acteurs économiques les plus
puissants de la planète donc
multinational multimillionnaire une
partie de ces recettes aillent
directement à l'ensemble des pays de la
planète en proportion de leur population
et de leur exposition au changement
climatique tu propose de sponsoriser
leur concurrence à notre égard
sponsoriser leur concurrence tu ce fr
qui vont se développer oui ENF attends
tu vois avant avant d'être concurrencé
par le Mali la France a de la marge
c'estd que pour commencer tu comprends
pourquoi je pousse le raisonnement tu
pousses le raisonnement dans l' en TER
de guerre économique non mais de guerre
économique attends là il faut voir de si
on leur donne de l'argent pour sécuriser
leur ressources mais tuend pas par que
non mais c'est pas rigolo non mais moi
tuisétais bamaco avant le covid un peu
avant le covid pour discuter des
partenariats avec des administrations
publiques là-bas et je les voyais tu
vois il me montrai les tableurs Excel
que la Banque mondiale leur montait de
leur envoyer des chiffres et cetera et
les types te disaient bah écoute nous
voilà les infirmières les instituteurs
ils ont pas été payés depuis 6 mois et
puis ils étaient payés 50 € par mois et
cetera donc c'estàdire que le niveau de
pauvreté de l'État malien ou de l'État
congolais ou de l'État Kenan enfin c'est
c'est c'est c'est quelque chose
d'invraisemblable c'est c'est le
meilleur rendement de la planète c'est
inves donner un million de dollars à un
gouvernement comme ça tu vois on prétend
ah non ça va pas être bien utilisé ça va
être de la corruption mais pas du tout
on a des état qui en fait ont besoin de
payer des dispensaires des écoles et qui
savent le faire et le fait de dire on va
toujours les contourner avec des
organisations non gouvernementales alors
qui peuvent jouer un rôle aussi utile
mais à condition que que qu'on commence
quand même par donner aux États
eux-mêmes la possibilité bah de de de de
pouvoir payer quand même eux-même un
minimum de de de service public donc le
partage des recettes fiscales sur les
multinationales sur les millionnaires de
la planète c'est quelque chose qui qui
va devenir une une nécessité absolue et
si on le fait pas et qu'on se dit bah
non ben tout ce qu'on va faire c'est on
va construire des murs sur la côte de la
militerranée laisser- les attendre que
les gens meurent par milliers par
dizaines de milliers en essayant de
traverser et puis après continuer de
donner des leçons au pays du Sud en leur
disant ah oui vous êtes pas vous êtes
pas assez démocratique et vous nous
soutenez pas sur l'Ukraine si on
continue de faire ça ce qui va se passer
c'est que c'est la Chine et la Russie en
partie qui vont tout ramasser en disant
au pays africains ou vous êes vous
développé donc bah oui mais pourquoi
actuellement on s'étonne sur les les
briques comme on dit Brésil Russie
Inde Afrique du Sud pourquoi on a des
des démocraties comme l'Inde qui qui qui
a plus d'électeurs que tous les pays
riches réunis le Brésil qui est aussi
une une vieille démocratie électorale et
qui a pas de leçons à recevoir des
trumpistes États-uniens qui souvent don
le mauvais exemple au Brésil pourquoi C
ces démocraties se mettent avec la la la
la Chine et la Russie dans les dans les
briques nous on s'étonne on dit bah
c'est peut-être parce que les leçons de
morale venant des pays
occidentaux qui qui qui passent leur
temps à donner des leçons de justice et
cetera alors qu'en fait les pays
occidentaux et leur systèm bancaire et
financiers sont toujours prêts à
récupérer les fortunes les plus
douteuses d'oligarques les plus douteux
pourvu que ça leur rapporte suff
suffisamment ces leçons sont tout
simplement insupportables et donc il
faut agir il faut agir en mettant à
contribution les acteurs les plus
puissants de la planète qui ne se
seraient jamais enrichi sans les pays du
Sud c'est qu'il faut bien voir que
derrière toute grande fortune il y a du
son de pauvre bah derrière derrière tout
l'enrichissement depuis la révolution
industrielle il y a disons un système
économique international où on utilise
pour ne pas dire parfois on exploite
mais on utilise en tout cas les
ressources de la planète les ressources
naturelles les ressources humaines
parfois de façon quand même très brutale
dans l'histoire du du colonialisme et de
l'esclavage mais les ressources
naturelles qui ont été surexploitées
pendant pendant des siècles avec les
conséquences qu'on climatiques qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui donc aucun acteur
économique riche aujourd'hui aucune
multinationale aucun multimillionnaire
ne peut dire oh bah moi c'est voilà j'ai
rien à voir avec le sud je je j'ai rien
à voir avec tout ça et puis dès qu'on
trouve de l'uranium au Niger et en
Mongolie là là par contre ça nous
concerne immédiatement on envoie
immédiatement les les les les les les
forces nécessaires pour s'approprier ces
ressources donc avant c'est pour
apporter la démocratie oui ben voyons
ben surtout pour les petites filles
ouais ouais enfin en pratique euh ce
qu'on ce qu'on voilà c'est cette
hypocrisie je pense n'est plus n n'est
plus tenable alors voilà on peut
attendre un rapport de force avec la
Chine la Russie ça qui va changer les
choses moi j'espère aussi plus je je
voudrais croire plus dans des forces
plus internes des forces sociales
politiques à l'intérieur des des pays
riches à l'intérieur des pays européens
pour développer une relance à la fois de
l'État social au nord et au sud parce
que finalement le point commun entre
toutes les classes populaires urbaines
et rurales en France mais aussi les
classes populaires au nord et au
sud au niveau planétaire c'est qu'on a
tous besoin de mettre à contribution les
acteurs les plus
riches pour bah pour financer les
l'école la santé et cetera donc à la fin
des fins la planète n'ayant jamais été
aussi riche il y a des il y a des
ressources pour résoudre tout ça c'est
après c'est une question d'organisation
nous on dit pas que c'est simple mais
voilà on pense que bah en essayant de de
regarder concrètement comment ça a pu
fonctionner dans le dans le passé on
peut on peut trouver des des pistes pour
Jul la tax sur les les transactions
financières qu'est-ce que tu en penses
et qu'est-ce que tu penses du fait que
la France freine des cas de fer bah
c'est pas vraiment étonnant non non al
attends avant il il y a un commentaire
de d'Internet qui dit question quelle
était cette version mensongeère de la
police avez-vous eu accès au rapport non
je ok il faudrait reprendre le déroul
exact de ce qui s'est passé mais je
crois que si je me souviens bien alors
peut-être je dire une connerie parce que
voilà maintenant toi tu peux checker en
ligne et moi je peux pas checker en
ligne mais la première version qui était
donnée par la police c'était que le
véhicule était en train de foncer sur le
policier qui av pas d'autre choix que
tirer alors qu'à priori quand il y a la
vidéo qui sort on voit que la voiture
elle est à l'arrêt et que du coup le
policier il est pas il est pas parti
pour se prendre la voiture qui arrive en
de plein fouet sur lui voilà je crois
que c'était ça en fait la première
version qui avait été donnée qui a été
contredite par qui était contredite par
la vidéo ouais pour revenir sur la TAC
sur lesou oui c'est sûr que c'est
complètement lié comme comme
question non mais il faut une taxe sur
les enfin je veux dire là il faut qu'on
arrive à penser des systèmes de taxation
qui se fassent au niveau international
de manière beaucoup plus juste que ce
qui est fait actuellement et surtout en
terme de redistribution des ressources
ensuite entre les différents pays qui
vont pouvoir en bénéficier ça c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est
extrêmement clair qu'à un moment donné
on avait mis en place si je me trompe
pas c'était Chirac cette espèce de de de
de taxe Chirac sur les billets d'avion
avec une espèce de redistribu à chaque
fois on est sur des montants ridicules
c'est ça le problème du truc c'estàd que
tu as des effets d'annonce et que malgré
le fait d'ailleurs qu'on va se retrouver
sur des montants ridicules tu as quand
même des pays du du du Nord à commencé
par la France qui sont toujours prêts à
à à s'y opposer en disant que ça va ça
va ça va poser problème je je donneris
un exemple je réponds à côté mais mais
pas complètement tu vois parce que tout
à l'heure on devait en parler on en a
pas parlé la taxe carbone aux frontières
qui a été mis en place ce qui pose à la
fois la question de l'Union européenne
la question du changement climatique la
question de la justice sociale fiscale
environnemental là on nous dit tout d'un
coup bravo on vient de décider au niveau
de de l'Union européenne d'une mesure
qui va permettre de lutter contre le
changement climatique et de lutter
contre une concurrence déloyale on met
en place cette taxe carbone aux
frontières donc ce ce mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières il
faut quand même regarder les chiffres
les chiffres c'est que ce que ça va
rapporter à horizon de 2030 donc déjà
pas demain à horizon de 2030 c'est
l'équivalent de 2
% de la valeur totale des importations
chinoises bon voilà donc si avec ça on
pense un qu'on va avoir assez d'argent
pour financer les service public de
qu'on va mettre fin à la concurrence
déloyal et permettre une
réindustrialisation de la France crois
faire de la lutte contre le changement
climatique et inciter des pays comme la
Chine à moins polluer et à moins faire
d'émissions carbone on se plante à peu
près sur tous les plans sauf qu'en fait
là tu dis aux gens aujourd'hui parce que
les gens du coup tu vas leur dire on met
en place ce mécanisme nous on a le temps
ça fait de partie de notre boulot que
comme chercheur bah justement de de
collecter des données pour pouvoir
essayer un peu d'informer le débat
public on attend de regarder la réalité
des montants et de se rendre compte que
c'est pas du tout à à la hauteur de
l'enjeu mais là les gens tu leur as dit
au grand public B on a mis ce mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone donc en fait ils y
croient sauf que ça va rien changer non
mais tu as quand même des gens qui y
croient parce qu'en fait tu leur dis que
heureusement que les gens font encore un
tout petit peu confiance Politi et voilà
et quand tu te rends compte que ça
marche pas bah du coup bah tu arrêtes de
croire en l'Union européenne tu arrêtes
de croire dans le politique tu pens que
tu peux pas lutter contre le changement
climatique et là on va sur cette
question on va droit dans le M on va
droit dans le mur parce que quand on
fait le point qu'on regardera en 2030
2035 bah ça n'aura eu aucun effet sur la
structure des flux commerciaux entre la
sur le chement climatique he bah ni ni
sur le changement climatique on
continuera de d'importer des trucs qui
viennent de 10000 km de là avec des
émissions vraisemblables mais mais comme
le le le mécanisme correctif aux
frontières qu'on a mis est juste
ridiculement faible en terme de montant
donc l'idée elle est pas mauvaise en soi
c'est juste que y un
moment regardez les montants les
montants sont juste ridicules donc ça ça
ne changera ça ne déplacera aucun flux
commercial ça ne ne créera aucun emploi
ça ne préservera aucun emploi industriel
quand on s'en rendra compte voilà là ça
ça posera problème donc il faut pas
faire des des annonces faut pas
prétendre qu'on est en train de résoudre
les problèmes quand on n'est pas en
train de les résoudre et en l'occurrence
nous ce qu'on pense avec juliia c'est
que la la seule façon là-dessus c'est
d'avoir quand même des mesures
unilatérales c'estàdire que c'est bien
nous on est européen on veut des
solutions européennes mais on peut pas
attendre l'unanimité l'Union européenne
vote en faveur du fait que on peut
importer plus de viande de l'autre bout
du monde et ainsi de su mais c'est un
problème on peut reparler du poid de
l'argent politique tuas un problème du
lobby tu as un problème du fait là ils
viennent encore de voter pour repousser
l'interdiction du du glyphosate enfin il
y a il y a plein de problèmes
aujourd'hui avec le fonctionun EUR c'est
pour ça que la France enfin ù chaque
pays individuellement doit pouvoir
prendre des mesures unilatérales pour se
protéger et ensuite si on arrive à faire
encore mieux ensemble très bien moi j'en
est pour une Europe du mieuxdant social
fiscale environnmentale mais ça ça ça
doit vouloir dire que l'Europe du mieux
disant que si on arrive à faire plus
ensemble c'est bien mais ça na pas
empêcher chaque pays de concrètement
mettre une taxe carbone aux frontières
dire au pays quand vous êtes sur un
territoire que ce soit en Irlande ou en
Chine où vous avez un un impôt sur les
sociétés de de 5 % ou 10 % et queun
entreprise basée en France va payer 25
ou 30 % bah le type qui produit ailleurs
qui exporte chez vous il y a un manque à
gagner c'estàd qu'il a il lui manque il
a pas il a pas payé 20 points d'impôt à
à l'entrée sur le territoire donc vous
êtes en droit de dire bah écoutez nous
on va on va vous faire payer la
différence si vous voulez exporter des
biens et des services chez nous alors la
différence par rapport à au
protectionnisme classique c'est que si
le pays en question en Irlande ou en
Chine réaugmente son son son taxe
carbone ou son taux d' lesé dans C
exemple à 25% on arrête dans ce CASL la
mesure de protection donc c'est une
façon d'inciter à aller vers le haut à
tirer les aut mais si on en vient pas là
et qu'on attend l'unanimité elle en est
où comment la balance commerciale
française elle en est où bah alors on a
un déficit qu'on avait jamais eu avant
qui est de toujours là de 50 milliards
d'euros ENF c'est un truc c'est un truc
invraisemblable donc donc ça ton chiffre
là c'est pas 150 non c'est pas 150 là tu
peux vérifier encore non mais non mais
150 tu vois ça ferait 7 points de PIB
non là on est plutôt à de de TR points
ce qui est déjà beaucoup quoi mais mais
alors il faut il faut prendre en compte
le la balance des services aussi he si
tu regardes que l'industrie tu pour tu
peux tomber sur des ch plus gros mais il
faut voir ce que rapportent les services
le tourisme et cetera donc faire
attention sur la balance commerciale des
fois les gens il regardent que les biens
mais bon si tu prends l'ensemble de ce
qui des flux qui r sortent et tu es
plutôt tu es plutôt sur l'ordre de 50
mais ce qui ce qui est déjà ce qui ce
qui est absolument énorme et qui est lié
à à ce à ce à à ce dont on vient de
parler là c'est-à-dire que tu ne tu peux
pas donc voilà nous on pense que là il y
a un moment il faut qu'un gouvernement
mettant de gauche qui arrivve au pouvoir
disent voilà ser bien qu'on en parle un
peu dans le contexte des élections
européennes aussi parce que là tu vois
tu as juste des élections européennes
dans dans dans 6 mois et personne n'en
parle de ces questions là serit bien
qu'on les mette sur la table qu'on ait
des propositions concrètes de changement
de l'Union européenne et le problème
c'est que là on est dans un espèce de
truc complètement binaire c'està qu' on
a l'impression qu'il y a soit tu veux
sortir de l'Union européenne parce que
tu la critiques soit l'Union européenne
on peut pas la critiquer elle est
parfaite bah nous on est plutôt encore
une fois on est fédéraliste européen
mais on se rend bien compte qu'elle est
pas parfaite et que notamment tu as un
vrai problème aujourd'hui avec la la
règle de l'unanimité et qu'il faut des
propositions de de de changement qui
doivent aller de manière unilatérale
s'ils le font en France sur des mesures
de mieuxdant social fiscal et
environnemental et c'est quand même
assez embêtant que tu es pas des
propositions fortes dans ce sens qui
soient porter aujourd'hui dans le débat
public français et c'est pas des
questions techniques hein dire quand on
parle de de concurrence fiscale quand on
parle de protectionnisme aux frontières
et cetera en fait on parle du job des
gens qui ont perdu leur emploi parce que
tu as eu de la désindustri istion c'est
quand même de ça dont on parle donc en
fait c'est c'est pas des points
techniques c'est des points concrets qui
ont un impact réel sur la vie des gens
et les gens croient plus en l'Europe ils
vont pas voter pour les élections
européennes ou ils vont voter pour les
élections européennes pas sur les
questions européennes parce qu'en fait
on leur parle pas de mesures concrètes
de réforme de l'Europe et il est quand
même un tout petit peu temps c'est pas
des sujets chiants c'est pas des sujets
techniques c'est des sujets profondément
politiques c'est des sujets importants
c'est des sujets où il faut du conflit
politique je veux quand même le
souligner parce que l'Europe avec le
climat c'est quand même des bons
exemples de sujets sur la sur lequel
voilà Macron va toujours nous présenter
ça comme des espèces de débats
technocratiques donc tuis tu aurais le
bon sens la raison les technocrates et
puis les oppositions déraisonnables non
c'est des sujets politiques c'est des
sujets de choix politiqu sur la question
de la taxe même sur la question
environnemental de de de mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières ça a
aussi des conséquences en terme de
pouvoir d'achat tu mets un mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières et
tu taxes davantage les t-shirts chinois
fabriqués dans des conditions sociales
déplorables le t-shirt chinois il va
arriver plus cher en france et des facto
pour toute une partie de la population
qui a pas d'autre choix que d'aller
acheter ces t-shirts à de TR 4 € parce
que tu as un problème de pouvoir d'achat
il va falloir compenser à un moment
donné donc c'est des vrais choix
politiques et il serait tant qu'on en
par non c'est pas ça qui va faire
augmenter l'inflation par contre pour
les gens qui ont des fins de mois
difficiles ça va ça va vraiment poser un
problème il faut il faut il faut réduire
les inégalités en même temps
c'estàdeffectivement il y a de
l'inflation sur les haut salaires qu'il
faudrait qu'il faudrait qu'il faudrait
qu'il faudrait réduire aujourd'hui
franchement l'inflation c'est pas parce
que tu doubles le prix d'un t-shirt sur
H&M que tu vas avoir plus d'inflation
par contre ça pose un problème de
pouvoir d'achat pas de marque c'est pas
de marque oui non mais c'était pas pour
faire leur pub hein on peut parler des
Ouigours attachés à ça et ça ça
contrebalancera le fait d'avoir cité
leur
nom pardon euh juste sur les questions
de guerre économique vous êtes chaud ou
pas chaud on peut rentrer plus en détail
ou Thomas bah de Guer économique ça fait
sujet garçon quand même non vraiment moi
moi tu sais moi je suis je suis pafiste
non seulement pacifiste mais moi je je
pense que on a on a moi je suis très
internationaliste hier je pense que dans
le fond c'est plutôt la concurrence
pacifique des modèles moi je pense qu'il
y a plein de choses à apprendre de
l'Inde il y a plein de choses à
apprendre du Brésil bon la Chine la
Russie c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
il faut il faut regarder et moi je crois
plutôt dans l'émulation des modèles et à
la fin dans des solutions coopératives
parce que as lu oui
oui ouais non mais tu as raison mais
sauf que en même temps je sais que j'ai
raison ouais mais sauf qu'en fait tu as
tur parce que en fait dans ben oui non
mais dans mais non mais je constate
simplement qu'au cours de l'histoire les
choses vont vers plus de coopération et
et plus de tu vois en en Europe bon
benah il y a eu les les guerres
mondiales et là on a fait l'Union
européenne et les chos continuent
d'aller dans le long terme dans le sens
du du de plus d'égalité par des
mobilisations sociales et politiques
donc c'est pas juste un truc un espoir
que ça arrive comme ça c'est c'est ce
qui s'est produit et tu sais les gens
avant la Première Guerre mondiale tu
leur aurais dit on va avoir un état
social avec entre 40 50 % du revenu
national mise en commun pour l'éducation
la santé les retraites les gens
t'auraient dit ah oui oui oui ou il
t'auraient dit ça va être le commun ça
va être le communisme oui ENF t'aurait
dit tu as qu'à croire tu as qu'à rêver
ou alors il t'aurait dit oh ça va être
le communisme le monde va s'effondrer
l'économie va ne va plus exister et
cetera sauf qu'en fait non seulement ça
s'est fait mais ça a marché ça a très
bien marché et ça a permis d'aller en
même temps qu'on a été vers plus
d'égalité vers plus de prospérité et
consommation et Jul alors bien sûr déjà
sur cette consommation énergé il y a il
y a deux trucs enfin un il faut la
limiter mais on peut redire ce qu'on a
dit tout à l'heure il faut le redire
vraiment fortement il faut la limiter de
manière progressive c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut que ceux qui consomment beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui fassent des efforts et
ceux qui sont à 4 ou 5 tonnes encore une
fois peut-être qu'il faut qu'ils
descendent à deux ou trois mais on va
peut-être attendre de faire baisser ceux
qui sont à 100 tonn d'émission ça c'est
la première chose et puis la deuxième
chose moi je suis pas du tout dans le
côté techno on va révolutionner la
planète et faire que des énergies
propres mais on peut faire quand même
plus propre que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que en
investissement en terme d'éolien en
investissement en terme de solaire et
cetera en France on est complètement
dans les choux on est complètement dans
leschou parce qu'on a fait le pari
pendant des décennies de dire c'est le
nucléaire ça coûte moins cher
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que ça coûte
pas moins cher parce que tu as tout le
problème du traitement des déchets et on
peut quand même faire mieux mais encore
une fois je veux dire si à un moment
donné tu taxes pas le kérosène et tu
régules pas le problème du trafic aérien
et cetera tu arriveras pas de toute
façon à résoudre ça parce par que c'est
pas quelqu'un qui a sa voiture
individuelle au fin fond de la Creuse
qui a pas le choix encore il y a des
gars qui sont à côté de de chez lui il y
a plus de train qui passent dans les
gares c'est pas en allant le le taxer
lui comme un fou pour l'empêcher de
prendre sa voiture de toute façon il est
obligé de la prendre pour aller
travailler qu'on va résoudre cette
question là alors je dis pas oui il faut
prendre les choses au sérieux oui il
faut voir combien on consomme oui il
faut mieux recycler oui il faut moins
sans doute changer souvent de vêtements
et cetera on peut en parler mais ça
c'est des trucs qui sont marginaux par
contre prendre en compte le fait que les
plus riches vont avoir des maisons trois
fois plus grandes prendre quatre fois
plus l'avion avoir des SUV x 2 et avoir
des piscines là par contre c'est des
vrais problèmes dont il faut traiter tu
vois cette question là on peut pas la
traiter indépendamment du de la question
des inégalités et en fait simplement
réduire les inégalités si tu oublies
même 3 secondes le changement climatique
vu la structure des inégalités
d'émission carbone simplement réduisant
les écarts de revenus ou de patrimoine
entre la majorité de la population
aujourd'hui est très riche tu résous une
une part de ta de ta de ta la question
de de de de de de changement climatique
et de consommation énergétique il faut
vraiment prendre cette question là au
sérieux quoi comme ça que tu peux
convaincre les autres de de de
changer le le leur mode de vie leur mode
de consommation de reprendre la marche
historique vers la réduction du temps de
travail évidemment fait
partieintelligence
artificiellee on va y venir mais juste
un truc par exemple non mais sur la
question de l'énergie par exemple si tu
as si tu as les gens aujourd'hui qui
chauffent moins tu as plein de gens qui
chauffent je sais pas 18 19 degr ils
font pas ça pour le changement
climatique 17 ils font ça parce qu'ils
ont pas les moyens en fait de payer leur
électricité ou leur chauffage c'est
quand même ça la réalité aujourd'hui en
fait c'est quand même avant tout une
problématique de pouvoir d'achat pour la
majorité de la population oui de pouvoir
de survivre si tu veux on le formule
comme tu veux mais c'est pas une
question de toi les gens c'est même pas
en se disant je vais baisser de 2 degrés
parce que tu as une campagne du
gouvernement qui m'aurait convaincu
comme par miracle que c'est moi qui suis
responsable dans mon appart de 40 m² du
changement climatique c'est pas pour ça
c'est juste pour payer moins parce
qu'ils ont pas de quoi à la la fin du
mois payer pour leur facture énergétique
donc faut juste un tout petit peu
remettre le débat là où il se situent
réellement dans dans dans dans dans dans
dans dans la vie des gens tu m'autoris à
dire un petit truc merci c'est
court commence pas à quelques jours de
la COP 28 oxam Oxfam pardon Oxfam publie
un nouveau rapport sur les inégalités
climatiques dans le monde ce rapport
révèle que les 1 % les plus riches é
mettent plus de CO2 que les 2 tiers des
plus pauvres de l'humanité soit 5
milliards de personnes magnifique on est
d'accord ouais
c'est ce qu'on dit depuis tout à l'heure
mais oui oui on est
d'accord question internet deux
questions Internet vous êtes d'accord
pour avoir un petit match de boxe avec
des économistes de droite non mais enfin
un match de boxe sans
sans ah oui c'est fait quand même domin
pendant 3it 30 HE de débat avec dominix
sur France interre à 7h45 le vendredi
matin pendant 3 ans 30h de débat c'estve
avec mê personne c'est héroïque al
pour les auditeurs je sais pas c'est
héroïque aussi oui après il faut varier
les les les partenaires les partenat
ouais non mais attends nous tu sais sur
ce sur ce bouquin un des trucs qui nous
a frustré c'est qu'on aurait aimé et on
aimerait toujours que les gens tu vois
de droite mais bien à droite quoi sur B
FM voir C news Europe 1 et cetera aller
au aller à la discussion Le Figaro
France attends on pe on peut critiquer
france télé mais c'est pas france télé
c'est news europeopen c'est pas la même
chose
ENF en tout cas nous on est on est on
est toujours pour la discussion
contradictoire bon voilà faut juste un
minimum de temps de parole faut pas que
ce soit complètement biiaiser mais à
partir du moment où des règles minimales
sont respectées alors je vous organise
ça vous inquiétez pas on s'est un petit
peu fait la main avec les pro et
antinucléaires et ça se passe très bien
chez nous parce que c'est moi qui tape
ouis c'est quand on se respecte pas ou
bah écoute on va vérifier les règles
exactement que tu as en tête quand même
parce que question Internet est-ce que
Bruno Le Maire est un péril pour
l'économie française a-t-il un impact
sur le destin de la France même pas
vraiment en fait c'est ça le il il est
vraiment platement conservateur enfin
c'est c'est un profil intellectuel et
politique très très classique
conservateur il y a un truc qui m'a
frappé pour moi c'est un pour la
littérature
françaisees aventures dans baignir ça
t'intéresse pas
trop
inér des romans à moiétifin bon mais non
mais attends tu mentionnais
l'intelligence artificielle il y a un
truc ouis il y a un truc que Bruno Leem
a dit récemment sur ence artificielle
qui m'a interpellé c'est qu'il a dit
attention il faut avant de faire de la
régulation il faut d'abord avoir plein
d'innovation et en gros tant que
l'Europe n'ura pas été super innovante
comme les Californiens faut surtout pas
trop réguler c'est ça c'est en gros sa
philosophie mais alors ce qu'on appelle
l'innovation dans ce domaine ça consiste
quand même à piller toutes les œuvres
tous les bouquins par exemple tout ce
qui a été écrit partout dans des livres
dans des journaux régurgiter tout ça
avec un gros algorithme en refusant de
rendre publ qui on a piqué et comment on
a régagité tout ça moi je c'est pas
juste une question de droit d'auteur
parce que bon à la limite voilà des
droits d'auteurs on en a c'est pas une
question forcément d'argent pour nous
moi je disais tout à l'heure les gros
droits d'auteur il faudrait les taxer à
95 % donc c'est c'est pas le problème
c'est plus une question de de
transparence c'est-à-dire que euh
récurgiter tout ce que vous avez
euh pompé palpé sur Internet partout
avec votre algorithme sans dire la
recette qui vous a permis de ressortir
tout ça c'est du mensonge organisé
c'estàdire que c'est comme si vous
donniez le droit d'enseigner ou de
soigner des patients à à n'importe qui
sans sans aucune sans aucun diplôme sans
aucune certification des compétences
c'est que là vous laissez des gens se
baser sur toutes les connaissances
produites par le reste de la société
sans vous dire lesquels sans vous dire
comment vous les retriez c'est c'est
juste du vol c'est du vol organisé et du
vol dangereux parce qu'à la fin on ne
sait pas sur quelle base ce que vous
racontez dans chatpt ou ailleurs est
vrai ou n'est pas vrai puis puisque vous
n'avez même pas à donner vos sources et
en plus c'est doublé quand même de
l'illusion de la neutralité
algorithmique qu'on a l'impression que
parce que c'est algorithmique c'est la
vérité c'est neutre alors qu'en fait
tout ça ça dépend de la manière dont on
a entraîné les algorithmes très
concrètement et donc si on les entraîne
sur des sur des contenus de droite bah
vous allez avoir un discours beaucoup
plus à droite si vous les entraîn sur
des contenus de gauche beaucoup plus à
gauche et on prétend que tout ça est
neutre et ça c'est un espèce de savoir
doit être transparent c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut c'est la condition de base pour que
tout ça est acceptable chatp ne devrait
pas être autorisé à à émettre dans dans
dans dans en Europe si vous ne rendez
pas publique la totalité de l'algorithme
et des sources utilisées et ceux qui
disent ah non on peut pas vous rendre ça
public et cetera enfin non je suis enfin
c'est tout c'est c'est vraiment très
simple après pour le reste ça peut être
très intéressant si vous faites ça en
toute transparence question internet
quel est le niveau de corruption en
France moi je pas voulez un pourcentage
du PIB ou non mais il y a de la
corruption il y a de la corruption
légale c'est c'est ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure c'est que quand pas de si
c'est légal c'est pas de la corruption
bah ça dépend ça dépend mais tu sais en
fait pendant un truc
intéressantégal non non non pourquoi
pourquoi on a complètement laissé
exploser le financement privé de la
démocratie aux États-Unis parce qu'à un
moment donné on a dit c'est la Cour
suprême états-unienne qui dit dit quand
tu as financement privé d'un parti
politique ou d'un candidat ça ne pose
problème que si tu as du quit proco
corruption c'est comme ça qu'il écrit
quit proco corruption euh tu tu tu as un
reçu pour un donné et ils disent que
tant que tu as pas d'échange direct
d'intérêt c'est-à-dire tant que bah je
sais pas moi je viens sur Serview je te
fais un chèque et je te dis bah je te
fais un chèque du coup tu m'invites sur
Non mais du coup ça c'est interdit c'est
la qu proco corruption mais par contre
tu pourras avoir un un moyen
complètement détourné donc ça va pas
marcher avec servview avec un autre
média du coup tu vas complètement
financer le le média tu vas rien
demander en en en terme de retour sur
investissement mais tu vas choisir la
ligne éditoriale c'est pas possible non
mais ça ça va être autorisé parce que tu
as pas un donné pour un rendu de manière
directe tu vois ce que je veux dire ça
dépend la manière dont on l' défini la
corruption le problème ensuite de la
corruption on défin de manière illégale
on peut pas vous dire c'est quoi
l'importance de la corruption parce que
si on le savait on lutterait contre et
on pourrait la mesurer question internet
pour Thomas
picketti d'après Jean coviss vous
connaissez
jeancovissi de nom Jean-Marc oui oui non
mais si ou d'après Jean-Marc jeancovissi
les flux physique entre parenthèses
pétrole camion matières premières fermer
la parenthèse se contract en France
depuis 2007 et donc en bout de course
une contraction des entre guillemets
trucs physiques à se partager comment
concilier cet état de faitte avec votre
affirmation que la France n'a jamais été
aussi riche merci pour votre émission
mais parce que parce B ce que ça montre
c'est qu'on peut être tout aussi riche
en en en en ayant moins de en utilisant
un peu moins de d'hydrocarbur et un peu
moins d'émissions carb on fait des
réunionit on est très riche de
réunionit qui rentre dans le PIB les
enseignants par exemple tu fais plus
d'éducation tu donnes plus de moyens à
l'université ton PIB va augmenter je
pense qu'on sera plus ris plus
intelligent collectivement et tu auras
pas d'augmentation de de l'échange de
truc pour reprendre la formule quand
j'augmente mon PIB avec la prostitution
les armes la drogue oui bah après il
faut il y a des émissions carbone
partout mais faut mais
effectivement mais les contenus les
contenus en émission carbone sont pas
les mêmes tu as
raison pas les mêmes suivant les
activités non mais c'est tout ce que ça
veut dire mais ceci là quand on quand on
fait la comparaison par rapport à 2007
où on se compare toujours par rapport à
2000 ou même à 90 et on dit on a baissé
les émissions carbone depuis 1990 bon ok
c'est génial sauf que on se place par
rapport à un niveau de référence 1990
qui a un niveau ahurissant c'estàdire
que le niveau atteint d'émission carbone
en France et dans les pays européens
entre 1960 et 1990 on est à des niveaux
de genre 15 tonnes 20 tonnes par habit
aux États-Unis 20 25 30 tonnes par
habitant c'est des niveaux hallucinants
c'estàd que c'est des niveaux que par
exemple même la Chine aujourd'hui où ils
émettent trop beaucoup trop ils
n'atteindront jamais ces niveau-l alors
en partie ils sont actuellement ils vont
ils vont dans les 8 10 tonnes ce qui est
trop vu le nombre nombre de personnes
mais c'est c'est déjà en train de
plafonner ça va plafonner ils vont
jamais atteindre les niveaux de 15 20
tonnes par habitant qu'on avait dans les
années 70 80 90 alors on dira c'est
parce que à l'époque les les les
technologies on était moins conscient
aujourd'hui les technologies permettent
de se développer en émettant moin c'est
en partie vrai mais ça n'empêche que il
faut quand même garder la mémoire du
fait que la façon dont on s'est enrichi
en France en Europe aux États-Unis c'est
en atteignant des niveaux d'émission
carbone par habitant hallucinant qui
n'ont été atteints par personne d'autre
au monde qui ne vont être atteints à
priori par personne d'autre au monde et
qui laisse des traces jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'estàdire que par habitant
on a une trace considérable et et y
compris avait en prenant en compte le
nucléaire parce qu'on a une façon en
France et parfois déjà un peu un peu
jankovici aussi de de dire voilà grâce
au aux génie français sur le nucléaire
on est beaucoup plus vertueux que les
autres bon en fait sur le bilan sur sur
les 30ente glorieuses et sur la période
1960- 1990 on est on est à des niveaux
tout aussi invraisemblable que les
autres pays et sur le nucléaire il y a
parfois des illusions euh technologiques
qui ont coûté très cher à Julia le
rappelit tout à l'heure le le le Pr
c'était censé coûter 2 3 milliards on
est passé à 20 30 milliards donc même en
en simple terme de coût financier c'est
pas juste sur le traitement des déchets
c'est aussi sur la technologie nucléaire
elle-même où on a une tendance du du
lobby nucléaire en France à dire vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir on va
avoir des rendements incroyables on va
exporter ça dans le monde entier en en
pour finir à la fin ça a coûté des
fortunes au contribuables français
c'estàdire que on a vendu à la Finlande
euh au Royaume-Uni mais notamment à la
Finlande des réacteurs dont on
prétendait que ça allait coûter 3 ou 4
milliards quand on coûté 15 ou 20 et la
facture ensuite elle a été payée dans le
sauvetage d'Areva et dans le dans le
sauvetage des opérateurs du nucléaire en
France elle a été payée par le
contribuable français donc cette
histoire ça devient plus rigolo du tout
y compris d'un strict point de vue
financier donc il faut il faut se méfier
voilà de de discours parfois un peu
nationaliste où on dit voilà nous on est
plus malin que tout le monde on a eu des
idées géniales et cetera bon là en
l'occurrence c'est des idées géniales
qu'on ne maîtrise pas techniquement donc
bon ça veut pas dire qu'il faut plus de
nucléaire du tout mais il faut regarder
très précisément tout ça en S ant un peu
des des discours nationalistes sur
l'éolien on a pris du retard pour pour
des raisons qui sont en partie des
mauvaises raisons parce que bon c'est
vrai c'est compliqué he de de de mettre
des des dizaines des centaines
d'hectares avec des éolienes de toute
façon dans cette histoire il y a aucune
solution qui est simple toutes les
solutions on tous des ça a l'air de de
faire calancher quelques boîtes là non
ouais mais mais pour
finir par rapport par rapport aux autres
solutions on appelle ça aussi des petits
mixeurs à oiseau ouais mais par rapport
aux autres solutions qu'on a on on on on
devrait quand même on devrait quand même
l'utiliser un peu plus oui c'est
intermittent mais de l'autre de l'aut de
l'autre côté bah non mais ça ça dépend
où on fabrique les PES et
cetera il y a non mais il y a vous vous
avez vous avez des pays en Europe comme
comme la Suède ou ou comme l'Espagne
l'Italie qui s'en sortent bien avec plus
d'éolien plus de solaire sur
l'intermittent c'est beaucoup peu de gaz
aussi les su non oui mais c'est non
c'est surtout c'est surtout l'hydro
l'hydroélectrique parce que
l'hydroélectrique vous pouvez lui le
faire vous pouvez faire tomber l'eau
quand vous en avez besoin c'estàd qu'en
gros vous vous retenez l'eau et puis
quand vous avez plus de de de de solaire
ou d'éolien bah Vous vous vous vous
faites vous faites tomber plus d'eau bon
comme ça paraît bête mais actuellement
maintenant vous avez des vous avez des
sites internet d'ailleurs qui permettent
de suivre heure par heure jour par jour
le mix énergétique dans un pays comme la
Suède et chacun pourra voir en ligne la
façon dont bah voilà mix énergétique
allemand il va bien bah lui c'est moins
c'est moins c'est moins vertueux pour le
coup mais en comparant ces différentes
situations ils ont plein d'éolienne ils
ont plein de machins à gaz ils ontt
plein de Charon he mais bon ils ont
aussi non ils ont aussi plus de ol
France ils ilst bien FCH avec le
nucléire aussi he ils ont aussi plus
d'éolien plus de solaire plus de solaire
qu'en France la France ils font quoi cet
hiver ils font ils font des feux de joie
ils font comment attends qui ça où ça
sans les Allemands sans les Français ils
font quoi sans sans les Français est-ce
que l'Allemagne c'est l'homme malade de
l'Europe bah non ils ont ils se sont
construits des rigidités là sur la sur
la dette
publique complètement complètement
absurde et là ils se sont coincés
eux-mêmes là c'est la situation actuelle
de ce point de vu ridicule parce que pe
coincé aussi avec les Russes non oui
mais mais là ça va ça va ça va au-delà
de de ça c'est que là ils ils se sont
coincés eux-mêmemes sur des règles
antiéficit ou là il pour essayer de s'en
sortir ils ont fait des fonds extra
buudgétaires ou leur propre cours
constitutionnel leur a dit non mais
attendez ça respecte pas votre propre
constitution là je sais honnêtement là
moi je suis en fait c'est pas rigolo
parce que vu l'état du paysage politique
en Allemagne avec la lafd qui est
derrière la CDU et tout ça qui je sais
pas s'ils vont réussir à changer la la
Constitution pour se permettre plus
d'endettement parce que dans le fond on
en a besoin c'est on est dans une
situation où le vrai endettement c'est
l'endettement climatique c'estàd que la
dette qu'on a vis-à-vis de la planète
avec le réchauffement celle-là on pourra
pas l'effacer d'un trait de plume alors
que la dette publique dans le fond petit
coup de canon ça passe he non la la
dette publique elle c'est un trait de
plume c'estàd que c'est des dettes
vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes on a eu des
dettes publiques après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale la Révolution française on s'en
est débarrassé en quelques années c'est
c'est des jeux d'écritures comptbl tout
ça ça ça c'est pas a rien de réel alors
que par contre la dette climatique ou la
dette éducative par rapport aux jeunes
générations qui ne qui qui qui qui n'ont
pas l'éducation qui devrait avoir ou
l'investissement dans la santé ça c'est
des dettes que tu viens de dire qui est
très intéressant si tu dis qu'on peut
l'effacer d'un trait de plume on
l'efface un peu comme la confiance mais
sauf que en fait à un moment quand la
dette devient tellement importante pour
rétablir la confiance il faut aussi
avoir le courage de s'en de s'en
débarrasser par des solutions
exceptionnell c'est ce qui s'est passé
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale tu vois
je pense intéressant c'est sur le truc
de trait de plume c'est qu'en fait il
faut réfléchir à la manière dont tu vas
répartir l'effort qui est fait
aujourd'hui en fait on prétend le le
l'effacer finalement derrière une cap
non mais c'est vrai derrière une cap
avec l'inflation et de facto c'est qui
qui P non mais aujourd'hui c'est qui qui
P pour l'effacement de la dette ou sa
soutenabilité c'est les plus faibles qui
se prennent l'inflation dans la figure
mais c'est ce que tu disais tout à
l'heure et du coup ce trait de plume en
fait c'est politique c'est des choix
politiques il faut
d c'est un peu mieux de faire payer ceux
qui ont les moyens de le payer plutôt
que de faire payer la majorité de la
population enfin non en l'occurrence il
plus pauvre les stress testes bancaires
ça vous
parle oui enfin tout nous parle je suis
pas sûr que ça soit passionnant mais
mais ça a l'air de t'intéresser donc
alors le pâté en croûte vous le faites
comment donc les stress ah bon les
stress Tess bancaire ça vous parle ça
vous parle pas est-ce que c'est les
lunettes roses est-ce que c'est un petit
peu le truc pour s'encourager entre
copains est-ce que c'est réaliste est-ce
que ça vaut quelque Choseon moi ça me
parle pas trop mais qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire exactement je je veux savoir
si les stress test bancaires ça sert à
quelque chose pour voir la la solidité
de notre système bancaire bah ça dépend
c'est comme tout he ça pe parler du paté
en croû ouais vas-y non mais ça dépend
ça dépend comment tu le fais ton stress
test bancaire et champion du monde du du
paté en croû ouis euh non mais attends
les nouvelles les nouvelles règles
banquelaires qui en gros ont demandé aux
banques d'avoir plein de de de plus
d'actifs sû qu'avant en fait ça a
surtout permis aux pays riches pour en
revenir à nos à nos à nos à nos
inégalités nord- sudud ça a permis ça a
aidé les pays riches à à payer moins
d'intérêts sur leur dettte parce qu'en
gros les le leurs banques maintenant
doivent avoir davantage de titres sûr
c'est quoi les titres sûrs c'est
justement des titres de la dette
française allemande états-unienne et
donc tout ça c'est ces règlesl on les
présente comme très vertueuse et cetera
et ça peut se justifier ça peut se
comprendre mais c'est aussi ça qui a
permis aux pays riches finalement
d'obliger leur banques à les financer à
peu de frais ce qui ce qui peut être
très bien pour le contribuable du Nord
mais pour le contribuable du Sud
don on y revient on en discutait tout à
l'heure mais ça reste quand même
fondamental c'est c'est en fait lui qui
paye l'addition quelque part donc il
faut toutes ces toutes ces questions il
faut voilà on a tendance à les voir un
peu comme un jeu Nord-Nord mais en fait
il y a aussi un jeu nord- sudud qui est
pas qui est pas un jeu forcément très
rigolo pour les pays du Sud le fond de
garantie des dépôts bancaires ça vous
parle oh là là tu es sûr qu'on va faire
toute la régulation bancaire là
maintenant là moi je viens plutôt
reparler des inégalités politiques en
France et du conflit terminer avec ton
homme avec le fond de garantie des dépôt
question de suite non mais attends vas-y
Jul moi ça m'enuie ouais mais moi
pourquoi il faudrait que je fasse pas
sur cette
question vas-y Julia parle de ce que tu
veux non une question quand même je suis
gentil question
internet que sont-ils prêts à perdre
pour mettre en œuvre leur solution
bah prendre moins l'avion par exemple
non mais ça me paraîtrait vraiment utile
parce que pour le coup une Desf toi déjà
tu tu le fais beaucoup moins et tu fais
des efforts une des contradiction si je
dois dire dans mon comportement je pense
que pour des raisons professionnelles
essentiellement je prends trop l'avion
et je pense que si on m'interdisait de
le prendre beaucoup plus ça serait
beaucoup mieux je serais ravi de de
perdre ça pour commencer par exemple
ouais non mais moi je je disais tout à
l'heure nous on on milite pour pour pour
pour se taxer nous-même à 95 % desè l'UR
qu'on voilà les écarts ne doivent pas
dépasser un 4 ou un 5 de revenu donc on
est on est très clair ça ça et moi tout
ce qu'on a tout ce qu'on a eu comme
expérience dans le passé enfin y compris
en écrivant des livres en les vendant et
cetera n n'ont fait que nous conforter
dans cette dans cette idée donc il y a
il y a aucune il y a il y a aucune
discussion là-dessus après nous ce qu'on
essaie de faire franchement nous on a un
travail très manuel tous les jours
c'est-à-dire que du matin au soir on est
là avec nos données on essaie de
comprendre ce qu'on peut restituer euh
au aux lecteurs aux citoyens qui sont
aussi les personnes qui nous payent
c'estàdire qu'on a une chance folle de
faire un boulot consistant à enseigner à
écrire des des recherches des livres en
sciences sociales à rassembler des
archives c'est un métier vraiment par
rapport à plein d'autres métiers enfin
que nous on trouve super agréable super
intéressant donc on essaie de de
restituer une partie de ce qu'on a
appris on met en ligne absolument toute
la toute l'appareil de de donné pour que
chacun puisse essayer ensuite de de se
faire une opinion différenteti consulte
un peu mais les politiques SS lisent des
livres c'est tant mieux mais moi je vais
pas voilà je peux pas les forer on a
accepté pour ce bouquin on va dire
Clement on a accepté d'aller au débat un
on a eu une invitation par l'Institut
laboci avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y
avait Mathilde panneau il y avait manuel
bonpard on a fait un truc qui était
assez rigolo d'ailleurs c'était un peu
le format d'ici ça a duré non non mais
attends j'ai pas fini ça va de 20h à 23h
et on a fait devant il y avait 600 plus
300 personnes quasiment 900 personnes on
a fait un espèce de coup four en
présentant des graphiques dans une
ambiance de meeting c'est vachement
intéressant on a eu un débat ultra
constructif parce qu'on était pas
d'accord sur tout ensuite on est allé
parler alors tu vas me dire c'est encore
la gauche on allait parler à à
l'Assemblée nationale avec un grand
nombre de députés nupes où on a échangé
pareil pendant 3 He avec 40 députés là
c'était fermé il y avait pas de médias
mais pour parler du fond là on pourrait
faire une blague en disant que c'est de
moins en moins à gauche on allait parler
à la fédé socialiste de de de de Paris
c'était la semaine dernière et
franchement si les gens de droite nous
invitent à discuter tu vois moi ça
m'étonne un peu posons les choses
clairement euh je veux dire un des
résultats qu'on monte dans le livre euh
c'est que le vote Macron est le plus
bourgeois de l'histoire je suis désolé
mais les députés macronistes ou les
citoyens d'ailleurs mais les députés
macronistes les élus ça devrait les
interroger et en fait ils devrait avoir
envie d'en discuter et d'en débattre il
se trouve qu'ils le font pas mais si
demain ils nous invitaent il disaient
bah allez euh ben expliquez-nous
pourquoi d'où ça vient comment on
pourrait faire mieux nous on dirit mais
s'il nous invite pas du tout on peut pas
aller parler avec eux je veux dire voilà
on est prêt prêt à aller au débat on est
content aller tu vois on on a pas peur
de répondre aux questions mais juste des
questions tois les stress tè Banca on
trouve que c'est pas fondamental mais on
pourrait quand même vouloir en débattre
mais sur des sujets sur lesquels on a
bossé non mais en fait la question c'est
surtout c'est pas parce qu'on est
économiste qu'on est capable de parler
de tous les sujets banqu bancaire ou
financier il y a des trucs qu'on connaît
il y a des trucs qu'on connaît pas moi
la finance c'est pas ma spécialisation
les élections françaises ou le
financement de la démocratie ou les
médias je peux t'en parler pendant des
heures c'est tout voilà je suis pas
pertinente sur l'ensemble des sur
l'ensemble des questions à un moment
faut pas faire illusion mais sur les
questions sur lesquelles on a bossé sur
lesquelles on est pertinent on a des
trucs à dire on est prêt à en parler à
tout le monde et pas qu'à la gauche et
en débattre et quand ils lisent des
livres les politiques ça nous fait
encore plus plaisir et s'ils ont pas le
temps de lire et qu'on va débattre et
discuter directement franchement on dit
jamais non hein question internet
devrait-on inclure dans la dans le PIB
l'état général de nos sols et du sauvage
oui de façon générale non mais le PIB
est une notion complètement déconnante
sur sur plein d'aspects le plus
déconnant c'est tu tu sors 3 milliards
d'euros de de pétrole de terre tu
augmentes ton PIB de 3 milliards alors
qu'en fait le pétrole il était il était
déjà là donc tu as rien produit tu as
juste sorti de terre un truc qui était
là en plus tu le brûles le moment où tu
le brûles tu fais des émissions carbone
qui font que tu réchauffes la planette
et tu as plein d'effets négatifs donc en
fait ça devrait avoir un effet négatif
sur ton pb donc déjà une notion qui est
un peu plus utile que le pb que nous on
préfère utiliser c'est le ce qu'on
appelle le revenu national où tu retires
la consommation de capital c'est-à-dire
que déjà quand tu quand tu sors ton ton
pétrole du du sol ou tu détruis des
arbres ou que tu détruis quoi que ce
soit qui était déjà là bah ça fait pas
partie de la richesse nouvelle que tu as
créé donc concrètement tu sors tes 3
milliards de pétrole du sol tu as ton
PIB de 3 milliards sur le revenu
national tu as zéro et si tu prends en
compte en plus les effets négatifs de du
fait de brûler ton pétrole tu as un
revenu national négatif donc on voit que
différentes définitions après te
conduisent à à à évaluer de façon
complètement différente différentes
politiques puis l'autre gros problème
c'est euh au-delà au-delà des effets sur
les sur les espèces vivantes sur le sur
la nature c'est la répartition de tout
ça et donc nous ce qu'on essaie de faire
dans dans le laboratoire sur les
inégalités mondiales que j'ai que j'ai
contribué à créer c'est de de montrer la
répartition non pas du PIB mais du
revenu national et puis au-delà de ces
échelles monétaires il faut on a besoin
d'une d'une comptabilité matière d'une
comptabilité matérielle c'est-à-dire que
voilà on peut pas tout ramener à un
équivalent euros ou un équivalent dollar
parce qu'à un moment donc la
comptabilité carbone indispensable la
comptabilité bah des espèces du sol
c'est c'est la même chose en fait depuis
la révolution industrielle la révolution
industrielle elle s'est faite en en
débloquant une contrainte écologique qui
était très forte c'est que la
déforestation elle existait déjà en
Europe au 17e 18e siècle elle a été
débloquée en gros en allant conquérir
des terres du Nouveau Monde en
transportant de la main d'œuvre d'
Afrique pour produire du coton du sucre
dans des plantations si le Royaume-Uni
ou la France avec de la vario des petits
gens des autochtones accessoirement et
et si le Royaume-Uni ou la France vers
1850 ou 1880 avait dû produire sur son
sol toutes les matières qu'elle
utilisait de de de de coton de bois et
cetera il y aurait fallu deux ou trois
RoyaumeUni supplémentaire en terme de
surface c'est des calculs que faisait
Ken pom Rance dans son dans dans son
livre de de 2000 sur sur sur pourquoi il
y a eu ça ce qu'il appelle la grande
divergence entre entre l'Ouest et et le
et le reste du monde donc cette
comptabilité matière elle était
indispensable enfin elle est
indispensable si on veut comprendre la
révolution industrielle du passé elle
est indispensable pour comprendre
l'avenir au 21e siècle donc donc de tout
ramener à une seule échelle monétaire
même si on remplace le PIB par le revenu
national je disais tout à l'heure c'est
un peu mieux mais en fait c'est c'est un
peu pourri quand même c'estàdire que à
la fin il faut voilà la comptabilité
euro c'est c'est utile pour certains
trucs pour regarder les inégalités de
revenu ça c'est c'est utile mais il faut
faire de la comptabilité matière bien
choisie pour pour penser l'avenir il
faut encadrer les
naissances
encadrer on sera assez mal placé pour
pour dire ça à nous mais encadrer les
denses c'est pas un vocabulaire qui me
paraîtrait très adapté pu c'est surtout
ce qui a été ce qui a été quand même
montré tu as compris la questionououi
est-ce que on est trop nombreux sur la
terre estce que non c'est pas la bonne
solution c'est pas d'empêcher les gens
d'avoir des enfants oui puis là on a une
population mondiale qui est plutôt
partiecl ouais est parti pour pour la
question c'est plutôt comment on va
payer la retraite que le contraire ce
qui ce qui des petits robots à
intelligence artificielle et tout une
population qui diminue ça peut être ça
peut être encore plus flippant qu'une
qu'une population qu'augmente alors
après elle peut pas continuer
d'augmenter elle a été mtiée par 10
depuis TR siècles on est on est 8
milliards on était on on était 600
millions bah d'abord à cause de fait que
les gens ont fait des bébés oui puis à
cause qu'ils ont arrêté de mourir non
mais à cause à cause du fait qu'il ils
ont arrêté de mourir en en basage ils
ont ils ont ils ont vécu un peu plus
plus longtemps donc c'est c'est associé
aussi à une à une progression des des
conditions d'existence de fait de
pouvoir vieillir avec des enfants en vie
et non pas enterrer ses enfants avant
soi donc c'est lié aussi à des à des à
des améliorations réelles dans la dans
la vie des gens sauf que système de
retraite a aidé tout énergétique la
consommation énergétique arrêter tout ça
donc clairement on va pas pouvoir
continuer au même rythme c'estàd qu'on
comme on est pas on a multié par 10 la
population mondiale c'était 600 millions
en 1700 c'est 8 milliards aujourd'hui on
continue comme ça on sera à 80 milliards
dans dans 3 siècles on a déjà changé de
trajectoire voilà donc on peut pas
continuer comme ça et de fait on a la la
population mondiale est plutôt
programmée pour se pour se stabiliser
quand quand quand est se met à se
réduire franchement ce qui est le cas là
en Chine au Japon ou à un degré moin en
Allemagne en Italie ça donne des
dynamiques qui sont bizarres c'estàdire
que quand quand les jeunes générations
deviennent deux fois moins nombreuses
que les que les vieux ça ça fait ça fait
une société où il se passe des des
drôles de choses bah par exemple
l'héritage devient un truc énorme dans
une société comme ça parce que les si
les jeunes sont deux fois moins nombreux
que les vieux ils touchent à la fois du
du père de la mère enfin pour ceux qui
sont riches puis de rien du tout pour
ceux qui sont pauvres donc ça donne une
importance à l'héritage plus importante
qu'à l'époque de de Balzac ou du
pergorio donc il y a plein de choses
étranges qui se passent dans une société
dont la population diminue qu'on n pas
forcément envie de voir non plus donc il
faut voir il faut surtout aider à ce que
les gens et les enfants qui veulent
avoir et en pratique ça va sans doute
aller plutôt de paire avec une
stabilisation de de de de la population
juliaen est-ce que tu veux parler d'un
sujet on a pas abordé gen le le vote
bourgeois ah ben
ça non non mais je sais pas il y a
énormément de sujets qu'on a qu'on a pas
abordé mais il y en a un peut-être par
rapport à la à la participation
électorale qui me semble vraiment
important c'est un truc qu'on défend en
passant dans le livre parce que le livre
il est il est long s'pp le livre déjà
une histoire du conflit politique
élection et inégalité sociale en France
et en couleur 865 pages en couleur le
Sarkozy il est plus cher 28 ou 29 € je
sais plus à 30 € beaucoup moins de pages
pH de c'est pas génial
pH non mais j'allais parler d'un truc
sérieux oui ben je sais plus non mais je
voulais parler de la question de la
parité sociale ah je pense que ça joue
un un un rôle enfin à la fois c'est un
reflet
l'augmentation non vas-y 2 minutes c'est
une augment c'est c'est un reflet de
l'augmentation des inégalités politiques
et c'est c'est une des explications de
la baisse de la participation ça si tu
prends aujourd'hui les députés en France
mais c'est aussi vrai aux États-Unis
c'est aussi vrai au Royaume-Uni en fait
c'est c'est vrai dans la plupart des
démocraties occidentales tu as des
députés qui sont pas à l'image des
Français aujourd'hui le pourcentage
d'employés ouvriers parmi les députés on
est en dessous de 5 % la mandature
précédente c'était encore pire on avait
0 % d'ouvriers et ça ça joue un tout
petit peu c'est-à-dire que quand tu as
la moitié de la population à qui ont dit
d'aller voter pour des gens qui ne lui
ressemblent pas c'est-à-dire qui ont pas
la même expérience sociale qui ont pas
la même expérience de terrain ça
décourage les comportements de vote
ettant qu'on prendra pas ça à bras le
corp c'est veut dire il y avait un autre
problème avant de ce qu'on appelle
représentativité descriptive c'était le
fait que les femmes étaient pas
représentées tu avait pas de député femm
comment on a fait pour lutter contre ça
on a fait des règles de parité femme
homme en politique je pense que cette
questionl il faut faire la même chose
avec la parité sociale il faut obliger
les partis par la loi à présenter des
candidats enemployés à présenter des
candidats ouvriers à présenter des
candidats d'orig à présenter des
candidat agriculteur alors le problème
c'est que nous on veut quand même le
faire en proportion de ce que représente
chacune de ces catégories
sociopressionnelles pas beaucoup
d'agriculteurs par contre il faudrait
plus d'élus qui viennent des territoires
ruraux au niveau national et ça ça peut
paraître une question anecdotique mais
quand même ça à la fois des conséquences
sur les politiques qui sont mises en
place ça a des conséquences sur la
confiance ça a des conséquences sur la
participation et cette question il faut
la traiter aussi de front quand on parle
de conflit politique quand on parle de
de de de de monter de la méfiance dans
la politique et quand on parle
d'absention électorale question
internet pour Thomas bonsoir que
pensez-vous de la que d'Angus don
concernant la science économique bah
laquelle parce que je veux dire don
c'est un économiste je dire c'est le
premier des économistes nouvelle
d'économie très économiste he mais on va
lui laisser spécifier sa sa question
mais on est très critique nous-même
envers la science économique on peut y
aller je peux répondre un peu un un peu
plus largement je je P il en a fait
plusieurs donc je sais pas je sais pas à
laquelle on parle là mais moi je je veux
dire que Julia comme moi on n pas
vraiment une identité sociale Julia
ch écoute je commence vas-y je fin je
sais ce que tu allais dire je
pensey Thomas comme moi non plutôt comme
économiste on a plutôt tendance à se
présenter comme chercheur en sciences
sociales on pense pas que l'économie ça
soit une discipline en soi qui faille
l'étudier de manière isolée on pense que
il faut étudier les les sciences
sociales dans leur ensemble ce bouquin
c'est autant un bouquin d'histoire que
de science politiqu et qu'il faut
enseigner en même temps l'histoire la
science politique la sociologie et
l'économie mais qu'il faut arrêter ces
espèces de frontières disciplinaires euh
absurde et une des enfin je sais pas si
c'est la critique que Titon mais une des
des critiques qu'on peut apporter à
l'économie c'est que pendant longtemps
par rapport aux autes sciences sociales
l'économie a une espèce de prétention à
la scientificité en se présentant comme
une espèce de science dure et du coup
elle s'est vachement mathématisée elle a
eu recours à des espèces de modèles
mathématiques pour dire bah justement
nous on est dans les maths donc on est
du côté de la vérité là où les autres
sciences sociales ne seraient pas des
science dur or l'économie en fait quand
elle sort du réel qu'elle sort du donné
qu'elle abandonne l'histoire euh elle
devient absurde et dit des choses
absurdes euh donc je pense que voilà ça
enfin c'est ça que tu allais dire à peu
près non oui ben nous on part on part
d'abord des archives on part on se situe
dans la ligné de de de beaucoup de
travaux de de chercheurs en sciences
sociales d'historiens sifried Paul bois
Charles Sly qui ont fait qui avaient
commencer ce travail le sifed 1913 Paul
bois dans les années 60 en collectant
dans les archives des données sur qui
vote pour qui dans les différents
cantons nous on a l'immense chance de
faire ça à une époque où où il y a des
moyens technologiques pour
numériser beaucoup plus de de de données
mettre ça en ligne donc sur le site une
histoire duconflit poliitique.fr mais on
se situe d'abord dans la ligée de tous
ces travaux d'historiens de de
chercheurs travaillant dans les archives
nous c'est notre seul matériel parce que
oui on é pas comme si on avait des idées
géniales que les autres ont pas eu quoi
notre seul avantage c'est qu'on a des
journées entières et on est payé pour
rassembler ces archives essayer de les
traiter pour les mettre sous une forme
intelligible et puis après chacun chacun
se fait son idée mais on on n pas voilà
on n' pas d'identité moi je dis pas je
suis un économiste je je suis un
chercheur je je rassemble patiemment
manuellement mes données on essaie de
trouver les les conclusions les
implications qui nous semblent les plus
logiques par rapport à ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a trouvé dans nos source mais
après voilà à chacun de se faire son
idée et et au-delà de tout argument
d'autorité c'est nous ce qu'on supporte
pas c'est les trucs d'autorité genre
voilà les économistes ont autorité
là-dessus et moi je suis pas économiste
donc j'en sais rien non attendez on
n'est pas et on n'est pas en mécanique
quantique on n'est pas en train
d'essayer d'envoyer une fusée sur la
lune qui on est en sciences sociales sur
des trucs où chaque citoyen peut se
faire son opinion là ce bouquin il y a
aucune technicité zéro technicité ça
prend un petit peu de temps mais en même
temps mais en même temps par rapport à
toutes les conneries qu'on fait tous les
jours de trucs qu'on fait par je pense
que lire des livres comme ça voilà ça
peut prendre une semaine 10 jours mais
voilà par rapport à tous les trucs qu'on
fait je pense pas que ce soit forcément
le truc le plus inutile puiss nous
conseiller à conseiller notre communa
bah moi je cons moi ce qui m'a le plus
marqué dans mes lectures à part les les
les livres d'historiens de scientiale
qu'on cite là c'est c'est souvent c'est
des romans parce qu'il y a une espèce de
puissance évocatrice dans la littérature
tout à l'heure je parlais du perregorio
Balzac le poids de l'héritage au 19e
siècle mais on pourrait dire la même
chose aujourd'hui tu prends un auteur
comme Carlos Fuentes gig magnifique
romancier mexicain qui est maintenant
disparu dans son roman La Volonté la
fortune qui est son dernier roman 2008
avant de disparaître c'est vraiment
Balzac au Mexique dans les années 2000
c'est tu as la puissance de de l'argent
les trafiquants de drogue des jeunes qui
hit entre entre mettre la main sur un
héritage ou faire du militantisme
politique il sont bon il y a une espèce
de de puissance évocatrice sur les
conséquences de l'argent dans la dans la
vie quotidienne dans la vie de tous les
jours bon moi j'ai pas du tout ce ce ce
talent juliaen plus de peut-être plus de
talent que moi pour ça mais bon c'est
pas tout à fait Balzac ou ou Fuentes et
si si tu si tu veux non mais
pe VI mais pour prendre TR écoute tu me
demandes trois titres je t'en donne un
trisè un trisème que j'ai lu récemment
alors qu' a pas la qualité de Balzac ou
fentes mais un auteur de science-fiction
États-Unis Kim Stanley Robinson qui a
écrit un livre qui s'appelle le
ministère du futur dans le gros il nous
il nous il nous imagine une solution au
changement climatique dans les dans les
décennies qui viennent ça se passe dans
les 10 20 ans qui viennent donc très
vite mais en même temps c'est pas très
rigolo son histoire c'est qu'en gros
tuas tu as une espèce de canicule dans
l'Inde qui des millions de personnes
après tu as un espèce d'écoterrorisme
vengeur venu du sud pour se venger
contre le Nord qui va se mettre à
flinguer les jets privés puis les avions
de ligne puis les containerses
commerciaux et à la fin tu as une agence
des nations- Unies donc le ministère des
futurs un peu désespéré de l'inaction du
Nord qui
va qui va bon bref bon bref qui se passé
bon moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que on
en arrive pas là quoi qu'on trouve des
solutions plus pacifiques mais au moins
le le bouquin bon qui est pas tout à
fait écr quand même comme comme comme
Balzac ou fentes mais mais qui qui bon
au moins traite d'une question voilà
vraiment centrale avec la puissance de
la
littérature qui voilà nous on n pas
cette puissance évocatrice après je
pense que le langage des sciences
sociales est aussi important est
complémentaire à celui de la la
littérature Julia les médias ça
influence le vote ouais bah ça ça a été
toutes mes premières recherches ma thèse
c'était sur cette sur cette question
question là bien sûr que les médias ça
une influence sur sur le vote un des
trucs que que que j'ai fait là au cours
des dernières années avec des coauteurs
avec camillevooie avec d'autres on a
regardé comment ont changé les
invitations et notamment la présence de
la droite de la droite de l'extrême
droite sur une chaîne comme C news après
l'acquisition par Vincent boloret peut
faire des choses comme ça sur le long
terme tu peux regarder tous les invités
en France entre 2002 et 2022 comparer
toutes les chaînes et regarder ce qui se
passe quand tu as un nouvel actionnaire
Vincent Boré par exemple qui achète ces
news qui rachète plus qui rachète C8 et
un des trucs que tu vois c'est que
l'extrême droite prend quasiment 20
points de temps de parole sur ces news
suite à l'acquisition par Vincent
boloret bon ben ensuite si les gens
s'interrogent sur le score d'Éric Zemour
à la présidentielle de 2022 qui quand
même était quelqu'un qui avait peut-être
écrit un livre ins suuccès mais bon
c'était un commentateur politique un
journaliste qui était quand même un
nobody essentiellement en politique qui
de septembre 2021 à ce moment-là son
temps de parole est même pas
comptabilisé par le CSA jusque à
l'élection présidentielle il a des
pointes dans les sondages quasiment à 18
% il finit 4e alors les gens disent ah
oui Zemour finalement c'est un échec
c'est 7 % c'est news c'est pas si
important je dire 7 % c'est quasiment le
double du score de Valéri pcè faut juste
remettre un ordre de grandeur et ça il
le fait en 7 8 mois et il le fait parce
que tu as une chaîne de télé qui lui
donne une plateforme médiatique
importante et c'est vrai sur ces news
c'est vrai sur europin là c'est vrai
avec tout ce qui s'est passé au Journal
du dimanche avec Vincent Boloré qui
impose une nouvelle ligne éditoriale qui
fait partir quasiment les les tr/4 45e
de la rédaction et qui met un service un
média au service de son idéologie et ça
c'est un véritable problème aujourd'hui
on n' pas assez de régulation et de
protection de l'indépendance du travail
des journalistes juste une question
est-ce que tu trouves que les médias du
service public sont neutre il y a aucun
média qui qui est neutre d'abord parce
que tu as tu as des positions qui sont
prises par les journalistes et c'est
c'est comme si toi nous les chercheurs
en sciences social on prétend pas à la
neutralité et les journalistes c'est
aussi des citoyens donc déjà tu as
personne qui peut prétendre end à la
neutralité mais quand tu regardes les
les les les invitations qui sont faites
sur le service public tu le temps de
parole que tu donnes à l'extrême gauche
à la gauche au centre à l'extrême droite
à la droite au différents partis
politiques tu constates qu'en moyenne
c'est un peu plus équilibré sur le
service public que sur un certain nombre
d'autres médias privé tu parles longemps
parent en pourcentage ouais je parle la
façons sont reçus c'est c'ests sont
reçus correctement c'est pas à moi de
juger enfin je dire je suis la dernière
personne pour aller juger du travail des
journalistes est-ce que les journalistes
interviewent tous les hommes politiques
de la même manière avec la même
gentillesse ou violence dans les
questions non on sait très bien mais
voilà on n'est pas là ici pour pointer
tel journaliste qui ferait bien son
travail tel journaliste qui ferait mal
son travail on peut toujours apporter
des critiques mais je dire c'est pas les
médias de service public les premiers à
être critiqués aujourd'hui quand tu vois
des dérives comme sur ces news ou sur
europin voilà mais ça veut pas dire
qu'ils sont parfaits ils sont pas
parfaits et d'ailleurs là-dessus pour le
coup s'il y a un truc sur lequel il faut
vraiment parler parce qu'on peut mener
des politiques de moi je suis pas pour
pointer des doigts tel ou tel individu
et dire donner des des des des espèces
de badge de bon comportement de mauvais
comportement bon intervieweur mauvais
intervieweur jeis pas là pour faire ça
par contre il y a un truc qui
m'interroge qui me pose problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ait supprimé la
redevance qu'on soit aujourd'hui dans un
système qui est ultra fragile où on a
juste attribué une fraction de la TVA
pour financer l'audiovisuel public ce
système a sait qu'il pourra plus marcher
à partir de 2024 et à partir de 2024 on
va faire quoi on va mettre le
financement de l'audiovisuel public dans
le budget général ça quand ça se passe
en h ou en polne on dit Aro sur la
liberté de l'audiovisuel public on le
met aux mains du gouvernement c'est ce
qu'on est en train de mettre en place en
France ça ça m'interroge vachement voilà
je veux pas juste applaudir les médias
de l'audiovisuel public non tous les
journalistes font pas bien leur travail
il y en a qui font bien on a moins bien
des émissions tu es plus ou moins
content on serait peut-être même pas
d'accord sur qui fait bien son travail
ou pas mais c'est plutôt les
fondamentaux qu' faut regarder et le
problème des fondamentaux aujourd'hui en
France c'est qu'on a supprimer la
redevance nous on aime bien edvig
Chevrillon alors elle est pas sur le
service public oui c'est vrai
sur BFM Business et donc c'est pour le
brushing ou c'est
pour pardon on dit pas les cheveux euh
tu me tu m'as fait perdre mon fil tu
l'as fait exprès comme d'habitude et
j'en peux plus vous vous
m'énervez tris livres euh bah du coup tu
en as déjà cité toi toi euh non mais
alors il déduction tu peux lui répondre
non non il y en a un qui nous a alors
est-ce que tu penses contre toi-même de
temps en temps en tant que historien
sociologue ou bah je pense enfin oui je
passe mon temps à le à le faire enfin
d'ailleurs enfin je veux dire le fait
d'écrire à deux ça nous fait beaucoup
penser contre nous-mêmees on finit par
par convverg all écrire quand on a
commencé cette recherche he que les
choses soient claires c'estàdire qu'il y
a pas un seul une seule ligne un seul
graphique par définition dont on avait
la moindre idée avant de collecter ses
données donc c'est même pas penser
contre soi-même c'est penser tout court
c'estàd qu'au départ on ne pensait pas
enfin je dire tant qu'on avait pas
rassemblé nos archives et qu'on avait
pas on ne savait juste on avait aucune
idée de ce qu'on allait raconter donc
toutes les les choses par exemple sur
l'écart de vote entre le monde rural le
monde urbain qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
les niveaux du 19e siècle moi je savais
rien de tout ça avant donc nous d'abord
on a appris des milliards de trucs et je
pense toute personne regardant tous les
graphiques sont en ligne sur le bouquin
il apprendra des choses après les
conclusions qu'il en tire pour l'avenir
sont sans doute différentes là chacun
est libre d'en tirer les conclusions
qu'il a pour l'avenir en tant que
citoyen mais le mais le mais tu vas
aller sur tes trois bouquins mais je
dire sur penser contre soi-même c'est
juste que on ne pense pas tant qu'on
tant qu'on trouve pas des choses
nouvelles donc nous on a on est des
chercheurs d'abord donc on a envie de
trouver des choses nouvelles on donne
nos interprétations pour la suite chacun
peut en donner d'autres mais sur les
faits qu'on met en évidence bah oui
c'est on avait aucune idée de ce qu'on
avait trouver je sais pas je dirais
violent Gérard le vote est fait au
village ça ça nous a beaucoup inspiré tu
tout à l'heure tu demandais est-ce qu'on
allait sur le terrain nous on fait
plutôt un travail à partir de données tu
as des gens qui font de la sociologie
électorale qui vont sur le terrain
violent Gérard elle fait de
l'ethnographie elle va parler aux
électeurs FN elle va parler aux
électeurs RN elle par permet de mieux
comprendre leur vote si on n' pas ce
travail là nous derrière on n pas
grandchose à faire dire à nos à nos
données donc c'est un peu cette
articulation avec les gens qui vont sur
le terrain parler directement aux
électeurs qui nous a profondément
enrichi ça c'est vraiment ça ça nous a
marqué pour ça sur mes recherches
précédentes il y a un bouquin qui
m'avait beaucoup marqué c'est un livre
de 2012 de Martin gillens qui s'appelle
affluence and influence qui essaie de
comprendre les politiques qui sont mené
notamment aux États-Unis et est-ce que
tu vas avoir des politiques qui vont
être davantage envers les préférences
des plus favorisés ou envers les
préférences des plus modestes et un des
trucs qui va développer c'est je trouve
que c'est un concept qui est fabuleux il
le fait aussi dans un livre suivant euh
qui s'appelle démocratie in amerriicaa
avec Benjamin page c'est l'idée de
démocratie par coïncidence en fait si tu
regardes les politiques que que veulent
les citoyens en général sur l'économie
sur le social sur l'international en
général les politiques qui sont mises en
œuvre ça correspond à peu près aux
préférences des citoyens ok mais dès que
tu prends des situations dans lequell
les préférences des plus riches et les
préférences des plus pauvres divergent
tu t'aperçois que les politiques qui
sont mises en œuvre elles vont dans le
sens des préférences des plus riches et
d'ailleurs il s'interrogent dans ce
cas-là pourquoi la démocratie fonctionne
par c'est quand même la majorité qui va
voter parce qu'il se trouve que par
coïncidence en moyenne les plus riches
sur plein de sujets ont les mêmes
préférences que les plus pauvres et une
des situations vers laquelle un truc qui
fait qu'on est aujourd'hui en crise de
la démocratie c'est que du fait de
l'augmentation des
inégalités bah tu as de moins en moins
de convergence entre les préférences des
plus aisés et les préférences des des
moins des moins favorisés non le
troisième je dirais là c'est plus de la
littérature mais pour le coup pour une
femme engagée moi qui m'a beaucoup
impressionné pour son engagement et
toujours aujourd'hui c'est an arnud je
trouve que voilà le fait de pouvoir
avoir le prix Nobel de littérature le
vendredi le dimanche est au premier rang
de la manif contre les retraites chapeau
il y a pas beaucoup de gens qui le font
plus beaucoup d'intellectuels
d'écrivains qui s'engagent elle elle le
fait et en plus de ça il se trouve que
tous ces livres je pense de la femme
gelé à tous les autres c'est quand même
extrêmement important pour la
construction de bah de l'indépendance de
la femme de la liberté de la femme des
droits de la femme euh donc voilà elle
j'inviterai plutôt à à lire son œuvre
complète qu'un seul livre d'ailleurs
elle écrit des petits livres qu'on peut
lire tout d'un coup on arrive à peu près
à 1000 page Thomas un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer quelque chose d'impérissable qui va
rester sur les
réseaux bah non mais lisez des livres
quoi VO je non mais vraiment non mais
c'est con mais mais oui non mais c'est
con mais c'est important parce que c'est
vrai qu'on est les les gens moi ça m'a
frappé j'ai j'ai trois grandes filles
qu' on 20 23 26 et là je on a une petite
fille de 2 ans et un nouvel enfant qui a
qui arrive et et moi je suis frappé à un
moment euh où il y a il y a un moment de
la construction à l'adolescence où on
veut tout voir des vidéos pour tout
démontrer tu as renoncé aux allocations
familiales euh oui ben je j'ai j'ai j'ai
renoncé je crois que là c'est la c'est
la mère de mes trois filles qui lesai
touché en l'occurrence mais euh mais là
pour au premier enfant on n pas deuxième
enfant on va avoir on va avoir des
allocations familiales on pour ça qu'on
est contre le contrôle des naissances
attends on peut pas là non mais attends
il faut il faut prendre ça en compte
dans les impôts à 95 % que je disais
tout à l'heure ça c'est c'est sûr il y a
pas de doute mais en tout cas voilà il y
a moi je je je me suis rendu compte avec
avec les mes jeunes mes jeunes ados
quand ils étaient plus jeunes il y a il
y a un moment où on attend tout d'une de
l'écran de la vidéo je si je lui dis
quelque chose oui il faut je veux voir
une vidéo qui me démontre ça et je
comprends il y a des outils formidables
et cetera la lecture dans des livres
comme ça voilà ça prend ça prend un peu
de temps mais je pense que c'est c'est
fondamental hein désolé c'est un peu con
con comme remarque mais mais c'est
vraiment ben moi je vais dire un truc
encore plus concom mais ça me paraît
encore plus central c'est qu'il faut
aller voter c'estd que je suis vraiment
impressionné par la la capacité de
mobilisation des plus jeunes tous les
gens qui pensent que les plus jeunes
sont dépolitisés et se plantent
complètement je pense qu'on a tous
beaucoup pour le coup toi comme nous à
apprendre des générations les plus
jeunes c'estàd que vous avez tuas les
générations F non non toi aussi euh la
il font de la marche climat de de la
greffe scolaire mais c'est aussi des
gens qui qui achètent plus de d'abisneuf
qui retournent au portable là neuf
touches alors que tu tous les parents
ont encore des iPhon ou des smartphones
qui qui qui en fait mettent leur
comportement de consommateurs et
justement de citoyens ils sont plus des
comportements de de consommateurs qui
les alignent avec leur préférence
politique et ça c'est vachement
important et ils arrivent à le faire
parce que je pense que ils ont été aussi
conscientisés à toutes ces questions de
changement climatique de justice sociale
de justice environnementale beaucoup
plutôt que nous et ça c'est vraiment
important on a des choses à tirer
là-dessus il se Mobilis il se mobilise
par les greffes par le boycott ils
savent faire des mobilisation sur
internet ils vont pas voter et c'est une
connerie de pas aller voter parce qu'il
se trouve qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui
décident politiques c'est encore les
élus ça se voit avec les retraites les
manif retraites elles ont été
gigantesques n'empêche que ceux qui ont
décidé au bout du compte tu vas me dire
c'est même pas les députés c'est le 493
donc faut aller voter et ça je suis
désolé c'est encore une fois ça ne
marche pas parfaitement ça marche
imparfaitement il faut réformer il faut
réformer l'indépendance des médias il
faut réformer le financement de la
démocratie il faut réformer sans doute
les modalités du vote il y a beaucoup à
faire mais tout ça on narrivera pas à le
changer si on va pas voter donc mon
conseil au plus jeunes c'est continuez à
faire tout ce que vous faites faites-le
en encore plus euh arriver à convaincre
tous les vieux cons de diverses
générations de de de faire beaucoup
mieux dans votre sens c'est de moi dont
je parle euh mais aussi aller voter tu
le travailles un peu tous les jours pour
changer ses habitudes de vieux con ou
pas mais en fait il en a moins que moi
c'est ça le
pire quand vous avez des belles filles
quand vous avez des adolescentes à la
maison je veux dire on a on a genre 15
20 ans de différents âges et en fait on
s'aperçoit très vite que 15 ans euh vous
êtes beaucoup plus vieux et vous êtes
complètement à la Bourse sur un certain
nombre de trucs hein Thomas picketti
Julia CAG merci merci
[Musique]
merci